This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina,
wait,
so you,
uh,
you're done with Vegas but we don't know
how you feel about it cause it hasn't
happened yet. We're recording
from the past into the future.
I am traveling recordings, time, travel
show I was feeling and what great.
I have a feeling it went
superbly well. Yeah. And I'm,
I'm excited to be chilling now and
just hanging out until this baby comes.
I got a month left and you were able to
incorporate those jokes I wrote for you.
Yeah, those are real hit. I
opened on. Um, well let me, uh,
my second kid is about to wreck this shop.
My Pussy is the twin towers and these
babies are hijackers number one and two.
Al-Qaida you done fucked up downtown
again. I mean it was winter.
Netflix is really stoked and
must be stoked about that.
They love al Qaeda jokes.
Most people touch such a
degenerate joke. Yeah. Um,
well that's great. Very excited, obviously
for you. Um, that's, that's that. Now,
where, where are you going
to be coming up? Jeans. Um,
November 24th house of Blues in Man Diego.
Wow.
And then I start doing the road in
December, December 8th, I think.
Grammercy theater in Ju Dork titties.
And that's it for now until we
add some more. That's great.
I um, I mentioned this last week. Uh,
brass balls beach Saturday was close to
God. Don't know if it's gone yet. Um,
Braya which is an August has opened up
like a 100 tickets each show because they
have a new location at a new size, new
capacity. So if you didn't get tickets,
they are now some tickets available
to each of the five shows.
Um, let's see. I think
that that one's gone. Oh,
there's some tickets left for the
second show in Boise Ball, Sacramento,
California at the community center
theater. Facteau I mean, Fresno.
Jeez. Um, October 26, Bakersfield.
October 27th, Jack me off fill
Florida. Okay. In the November,
Orlando, the day after that, fill
her up. Delphia oh, and Eugene,
Eugene,
Oregon was added also in October.
You can get all those
tickets@tomsegura.com click
on the tour page tickets.
All right, Jean, let's get into our show.
Let's get into our show.
There's so much to go over.
We have a great guest on the way.
Okay.
It's going to be a lot of fun today.
O M g o g
g here, yet Google their main
or she loves memorial day.
People like her. Uh, the Moose Soup Lady,
they live for three day weekends. Oh yeah.
Moo Moo soup lady is, is, uh,
is definitely celebrating.
She's one of those that like, she's
got the picnic. She's doing that.
She's hosting the Barbie now.
It's confusing to people because it's way
past memorial day. Oh Shit. Sorry guys.
But we're recording for the buyers will
say it recording on Memorial Day. Yeah.
The moose soup lady loves those
kind of holidays. Like o m.
G she's hosting all of the parties.
Really celebrating the day off, you know?
Yeah, I kind of Shit. All right.
Here we go. It's your day job a lot.
I need some dick badly.
I'm fucking tired of wasting
this good ass fucking pussy.
Oh yeah. I'm fucking tired of it.
I'm fucking tired of my pussy.
Just fucking white spin.
Oh, is Randy. Don't
bring anyone in loving.
Well,
go to your mom's house.
Did I know who you are when you do
that? When you play Air Guitar? Yeah.
You're the fucking dude from
the Bruce Springsteen band.
The ECP street who became an actor. Oh
yeah. Little Stevie. You're that guy.
Yeah. Little Steven. You look
just like him when you do it.
Like you got the the dad.
Yeah. Yeah. Feeling that. Gosh,
I hate that band. Yeah. I also, I
think he like Frank Sinatra. Yeah.
We hate when Springsteen, Bob Dylan,
the three people I hate the most.
I hate those people too.
And that's why we are married now.
There's some things we digress on.
Yeah, of course as well. I think, uh,
I would rather bring back some dictators
if it meant we could get rid of those
three. Do I mean obviously
one's dad. Sorry. Thanks.
Ooh,
I'm just a blue collar.
It's a blue goose Puma boots strips off.
I think I have a hard time
buying that because he's a,
he's like a millionaire millionaire
many times over. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
It's kind of hard.
I don't like Bob Dylan either,
just cause it doesn't make it in
the bag and Lizanne and I'm like,
I just don't really, I just don't
understand pretending to think it's good.
I mean, the very first time I heard I
was like, this is dog shit. Who is this?
I was Bob yelling at this is
what people talk about. Yeah.
This guy is who celebrated.
I'll tell you though,
there's people listening right now that
their heads are exploding because they
absolutely, they love these people. They
don't know what the fuck's going on.
Who Was it? Hello? Frank Sinatra.
Yeah. We hate, I don't hate him.
As much as I hate the hate him,
I just don't
pretend that it's like a real singing
that's not singing. It's singing songs.
Yeah. He's just been a lucky guy.
Be So lucky. That's shocking.
Fog Up. Sing talking. Yeah.
Yeah. It's that. Hey. Ooh.
By my luckiest guy on the block
prep pap pap. I'm like, okay.
I know we've talked to him about this.
There's a lot of stuff that people like
that I hate most. Most current music.
I don't understand it. A lot of
it's done shit. Fucking get it.
Every time we're in the,
in the country club and they're pumping
some shit through the, I'm like,
what is it? Is this, I
will say that I like,
um, new discoveries when they're
good, like anybody would, right.
It's like somebody says, try this food and
you're like, Whoa, what the fuck is it?
Like, so music wise, you know,
like I, I got into Thundercat
over the weekend. Yeah.
Play that for me. And I was like, this
feels like Stevie wonder. It feels,
it feels familiar, but to me it's a new
discovery. I was really excited about it.
You like daft punk lately.
I like that new, uh,
Pusha t album a Daytona,
which I'm, I mean I knew, I
obviously knew who he was,
but I'm saying it's like when something
new comes out that you can get excited
behind. I really much, I mean,
Kanye made the beets and it just,
it further prove my point when everyone
was accusing him of like whatever.
He might be going nuts or
whatever. I was like, yeah,
but they won't care if he makes drops
that heat on the gun. Yeah. And those,
uh,
those
saying, oh, I like Cardi B. There
you go. Um, she and I shared today.
Thank you guys by the way,
for tweeting her. Yeah.
A lot of sweets and that is exactly
what we want it to bombard Cardi B with
tweets about,
oh my God,
you set up the pregnancy with Christina
and she on Instagram posted a video.
She's like,
I just got to thank my baby for giving
me this luscious hair and these big
boobs. You know what I'm
saying? Like she's, she really
is all about it right now.
And I agree. She and I are, you know,
pregnancy besties, yes. For pregnancy.
Betsey's yeah. I like, I love my hair to,
my hair doesn't get that good. But anyway,
it's interesting. She and I share a due
date. It's very, we're going to have a,
I mean a little different.
She might do water births together.
She's going to fly out here. She might
do a actually announced that gender.
We're going a little different
route. You know, what's Your Pronoun?
You don't and believe on an
inflicting that kind of thing.
It's for them to decide. Yeah. Our,
our nursery is totally gender neutral.
[inaudible] yellows,
Greens, orange. I don't believe
in specific toys either.
I also believe in asking every
day. Yeah, let's do like today.
What are you today?
Especially starting around six months old,
I asked for consent when I change
their diaper. Always asked for consent.
When you change a diaper feed, you know,
pick them up, bathed them and then,
cause that works, right. We're
asking, we have experiences with,
with one so far and they,
they're really good at signaling when
they want to do things that are for there
or the word yes. We hear the word
yes a lot from a toddler. Yeah. Yeah.
It's one of their first word.
Yes. I'm thinking about it. Maybe.
Let me consider the options. They're
very rational, you know creatures. Sure.
So, um, well that's one of the
reasons I don't have baby showers.
I don't believe in having that binary
structure. Yeah. On gender mix.
Lots of people giving me
gender specific things. Um,
I will say it is rare
but always a treat when full.
First of all,
when to like for instance when
a couple of weeks ago when um,
the female listeners sent
in there try it out videos,
which is a really a spectacular treat.
And then now when we get a video like
this where it's a woman saying she wants
the sex, cause there's, I'll,
I'll let you know a little secret.
There's no shortage of men out
there who make requests like this,
but when it's a lady,
it's a very special thing.
Well it's a role reversal
where generally not that, um,
forward about our sexual needs and desires
forward is, is a understatement
for this. I think.
Yeah. I want to get fucked meal. Okay.
I should be able to get fucked when
I want to get fucked. She's running.
I worked so fucking hard and I never got
no fuckin time to get no fucking Dick.
Like this shit is.
Yeah. Well, she does have a point. Look,
she's a very attractive woman. She works.
I feel like women,
it's easier for us to get lazy.
She should be able to walk with her prop.
Why didn't she should be able to walk into
like a park and go, who wants to fuck?
And then a guy that I think maybe she has
like a like is the problem
that she's going after.
Sure. Unattainable men are
like, no, you can't not get sex.
She's going after losers.
That's the problem. Losers.
But she's not even getting it
from losers. It doesn't, it.
She's getting it from scumbags.
My,
my thinking is she's
attracting the wrong kinds,
but she's saying, Fuck Neil. Okay.
I should be able to get fucked
when I want to get fucked.
Did she say she can't get it? Period?
I don't know what's happening. I mean,
is she going to the right places?
Are you going to bars? I don't know.
Are Willing to go to la.
I deserve
to be getting my face fucked
right near your face and my dope.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Suffocate me. Talking dot.
You can go to fuck tablet and fuck
who I want to fuck up there too.
Mm hmm.
She might have some
new doctor drew.
Yeah.
Fuck me lady.
Yeah. By the way, I always,
uh, as always a huge thing.
So Dr drew.
Okay.
I loved it. We love it. Yeah. I
mean when he's here he thinks I'm,
I'm being a little, is it
sadistic one? Yeah, he was,
I was really happy cause he was getting
on you more than me. This, yeah. He,
he really,
he thinks that I'm laughing
at his uncomfortability
and upon further specular,
uh, analysis analysis. I
think some of it's that,
but I think some of it is also the of
having somebody so over qualify like a
legit doctor. He's also been, you know,
40 years treating people with a DA,
like he's really overqualified and
having him watch are ridiculous videos of
course,
is such a joy for me and I get giddy
knowing that we're asking him to analyze
these ridiculous videos. It's
just, it's my most favorite thing.
There's one or two things going on here.
This is either a smart lady who realizes
the comedy and doing this and she's
doing it because she knows it will get
tons of views or it's a very mentally
unstable person.
She should give out her address like
the guide does and try it out. Guy,
she would get lots of responses.
You got to get up.
You got to give back to her address or
your phone number if she wants to respond.
Let's see, cause that's your so
far. I mean, see, here's my point.
Like there's no way this
lady can't get someone to,
she's cute was Ding Dong in her
throat. Yeah, that's easy peasy.
Request that be a challenge. You know?
She's like, no one will do it. Bullshit.
You'd do it, but do it right now.
If she was in the other room,
I just walk in there and do it and be
like, is this what you needed? It's,
and it's a silly thing.
That can't be true.
I can't do this no more.
I need some fucking Dick like this.
I can't live like this.
Like what the fuck?
I got some good at Olympian Olympian.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Worldstar clips.
Okay.
There it is.
That's the reason.
Oh man, she's an angel.
I don't understand what,
well, the, the, the overt crazy as a
deterrent. Yeah, it might be the problem,
but it's still, I would still
go in there at least for one.
One not cause she, you know,
she's going to blow up your phone.
There's going to be multiple texts.
There's going to be followup call.
She might find your fucking home and
stock. You went, this bitch is too crazy.
That's the problem. You go to her
place to give her a fake number.
I mean 35,000 texts girl 65.
Oh Shit.
Don't just leave 30,000 on the table.
That's the problem.
That's too bad. Put It on my throat and
he ain't going to fuck me from the bag.
Love this girl.
You love it.
All that stuff.
You joke about. You love her. She's great.
This is your second
wife. This could be, it
should be good influence. Great mom.
Yeah. That's all I'm thinking about. Yeah.
Now,
speaking of love affairs,
particularly yours and mine, um,
yesterday you came downstairs.
She had been fighting this cold,
getting over it and in the morning we
have some coffee before we pick up LJ from
the crib and you were hawking and
bringing up your phlegm in the kitchen
as we were talking and drinking and I
look over and I'm like,
Eh, it's okay. All right.
I held my tongue and then you got up.
I didn't when I did,
when I saw you
hawking a loogie into our kitchen sink,
sink the bar. It's somewhere that
we wash our hands, we wash glasses.
The kid plays in like not really an ideal
place for hogging like a sick loogie
and I called it to your attention.
I was like,
do you think you could make me not do
that in the kitchen and do that in the
bathroom? And I swear it. The
look on your face was like,
what? Like you were indignant
like righteous indignation.
Like I can't believe this bitch is
telling me I can't hock a loogie in my
kitchen saying it was, it was,
yeah, it was. It was, you know,
it was kind of annoying.
It's annoying.
Especially because at that bathroom was
like five whole steps from where you
cock the five steps. I mean, here's
the thing, you know, when you're,
when you're getting through, fighting
through and getting out of a, uh,
sick a bronchial thing,
worst time is definitely the morning for
cleaning it because what happens is you
sit there, I know. And that
stuff just drips all night.
So you wake up and it's just,
uh, it's like you're coming,
you really come in through some,
some dog shit. So you know,
the first thing is you
take your morning pice.
I now know no line now with you, it's
a medley of sound. I know, you know,
it's interesting cause I know what you're
doing in the next room just based on
sounds. The other day I was like, oh are
you scratching your nuts? And you're like,
how'd you know? I'm like, cause
I can hear it. I know the,
I know what each one means.
Like a deeper,
that's about scratch. A lighter
sounds, the front scratch.
So when you get up to pee and there's
multiple farts, that's a morning pee.
Generally not at night. It's a
specifically a morning. Sure.
So when I got down there,
I was ready to drink my coffee,
but then I just kind of took
a deep breath. I was like, oh,
there's some stuff to bring it up.
Then I brought it up in the kitchen.
I wasn't really thinking,
you know? No, I know.
I know you weren't fun part I then,
I
know before that you had a
paper towel that you would like,
like a dirty paper towel you'd found on
the kitchen table and then that one you
were spitting into. Oh, I
forgot. I block that one out.
I almost vomited.
I almost vomited and I thought
surely he can't take this further.
And that's when you got up and you,
while they were jumping over the fact
that when my first got up I was like,
I got a pretty big boner right now.
Right. Which is kind of normal for you.
But then your choice of like courting me
and getting me on board with the, yeah.
Was the Hawk and horrific and make
these sounds and be disgusting.
So like in your mind you're like,
oh I got this bone or I love my
wife to help me out with it. Like,
and then every flower blooms
differently. Yeah. Yeah.
Color.
I got this boner.
So gross. I like how you're
like, why don't you give me
blow jobs? I'm like, mom,
you know, seven a half months pregnant.
I just barfing to my own mouth all day,
which I'm fine with.
It's really not what I want to do that no,
but I mean I don't, I wouldn't let
it, I wouldn't be bothered by it.
I would just have constant
heartburn. My bad. Yeah.
Anyways, that was our sexy life
yesterday. Then we watched a sexy movie.
Yeah. Molly would avoiding
this movie. I know.
I don't know why. I think it's just,
I'm not a fan of the, uh, the artwork.
I might have found a trailer.
Yeah.
Movies much better than the artwork
or the trailer. Well the artwork,
you know why you don't like it?
Cause it looks like it's marketed to women
because they use a pink font, I think.
And so I'm sure guys are like,
I don't want to watch some chick movie.
And it's not really a chick movie at all.
Check movie.
She's a woman who is doing extraordinary
things and it's interesting. But yeah,
they didn't market it correctly.
It's Jessica's to chest
day in and she plays, um,
Molly bloom who was an Olympic skier and
then ended up running poker games like
exclusive poker games in Los Angeles
and later in New York too. Dark titties.
Yeah. And uh, anyways, it's a great,
it's a really cool story. It's,
it's really well done movie
about gambling, but it's
more about her tests. Well,
her tits were spectacular. They were
out the entire movie tire. There wasn't,
there was one scene where they
covered the up and I thought this,
I wonder why they're covering it.
I'm up now just to kind of,
it's the kind of movie and the kind of
tickets where you're wondering why there
isn't a more in depth conversation about
her kids in the movie because he does
bring it up once her attorney is like,
you may want to dress down for court.
Like that's right.
I thought he was going to be like,
that judge is going to ask the
suck on her tits or something.
And I have to say as a, as a
cisgendered woman, heterosexual,
I didn't, I normally don't. I'm
not fascinated by tits. The whole,
I was like enraptured looking
at it only that you, um,
right away started the conversation.
You Go, do you think they're real?
And my immediate feedback was 100%.
I think they're real now. See,
let's talk about this because
she's very petite. She's very tiny.
She was very clear to have such
big cans on such a small body.
I could tell that there was
a lot of help in, in uh,
giving out that type of cleavage.
Other words,
there was a supportive bra and tight,
close up top pressing those
two photographs of people
watching can see what
you're talking about. She's, first
of all, she's very beautiful.
She's very made up in this film. I think
every single scene. She's got full hair.
Full makeup. Yeah. At a certain
point. Yeah. She's super,
super made up and every dress
is like a titty showcase stress.
Yeah. Even court. She's wearing like a
titty. You can see there's her tits there.
Her tits are there. See I do think they're
real action real. I think the real,
they have a natural, they have
a natural drop to them. Yeah.
And then they're just exposed more.
And this bra is lifting them
up and pushing them together.
Which giving this, uh,
you know the cleavage, which is really
nice. The thing I will tell you,
a big fan of her droop.
Here's how you can tell by the way is
the real good girl right here where the
real girl and she's got big tits to yeah.
So the thing is she looks like she
definitely is down. She's real pretty too.
She's just the real girl is prettier
than Jessica Chasteen I aren't there.
See now here's is interesting is
that that looks like a faker. Faker.
Here's how you can tell if tits are real.
If when you put them in at raw,
they mashed together. Okay. That,
that like fat lady cleavage where the
tits are real tits mushed together cause
it's squishy. Fakers separate.
They're, they're a part,
there's a big cavern between the two
now. It could, it could just be her bra.
Yeah. See I can't tell cause there was
there it wasn't like real hangers. Yeah.
Yeah. But then sometimes they
look fake cause she's so petite.
This is all the movie stuff.
This is her at um,
a premier right here and they look well.
Is there any like casual tip pictures?
So this is her at a movie premier.
She, she'd got the side spillage here.
That looks like real tit meat.
Cause my tent meet.
We'll do that cause fake tits.
You'll kind of see the bag like there
are hard and you see those fall real.
See how they're mushed
together in the middle. They're
nice. Yeah. Not the perfect.
He's got real nice tits.
Wait until she pumps out a couple of
kids that we can get her on the show.
Join them now I would love is
the articles about her cleavage.
Oh cool. Keeping it classy.
Oh she's still 40. Damn.
Really? She ain't got no kids.
That's why they'll titties.
Look all night if she doesn't have kids.
I'm just assuming maybe she had him
lifted after some bitches are lucky they
have kids or tits. Pop
right back. Hi Mine Minor,
the state troopers for life.
I had to get something done,
especially with a second kid.
It's a disaster now. See that's,
that's the outfit she wears
in court and then there real,
the whole, everything is about those
tits. Molly's, Molly's takes ticket.
But it was, it's a good movie. If
you guys were looking for a movie,
you haven't seen it.
I think it's uh,
it's definitely an entertaining
and you like tits. These,
this is the kind of show you're
going to, like, you got a wife,
it doesn't let you look at stuff.
You can be like, let's watch Malia.
I heard it was a really cool story.
And then you stare at Ted's room. No,
interesting analysis, Tom. But
here's the thing. So I texted, uh,
this fun of ours. He works as
a stylist. He'd silo styles,
all these celebrities, you know, I
said, do you know Jessica Chastain?
You work with her? He goes, I
don't style her. I asked him,
do you think those tits are real? He
goes, oh, yeah, yeah, those are real.
I've seen her before and he's a gay
guy, so guys, they know this stuff.
They really know.
Um, according to this, I don't,
I don't think she has kids.
Yeah. That's why those titties
look nice. Yeah. Yeah. She, she 40,
she had tests like that.
I ain't got no kids. It doesn't say
here. I mean, it says that she's, uh,
she's married,
looks like to a real fucking Guinea.
Gian look up bossy that,
that see an actor and he's
a normal person.
Just, uh, yeah. Anyways.
Yeah. But those tickets are,
they're really something.
And her teeth are nice and white too.
Like she has really white teeth.
I admire that. She has really
nice teeth. Those are important,
especially as a movie star. Now,
you know, you're a movie star now.
Do you think you'll get yours whitened?
Um, uh, there's still a little, oh,
it was right. By the way,
this, this Italian guy, he's
the count of the Busey the,
but at both Soulo noble
family cheese account. Yeah.
That's cool.
He is an executive for Montclair and uh,
she married him at his family's estate
and got up on that. I eat Dolly.
Wow. Wow. What's your title?
My name is Sir Thomas Testes.
Reigning King of working,
working in farting,
farting and burping here and gross.
That's me. I'm in charge now. I know.
Um,
oh,
this is a account
is,
yeah.
Apparently my son from my
previous relationship,
oh shit.
I hit in the face. Oh my
goodness. Cigarettes down.
Do you know that
25 times a week people send
me a link to Jean Segura.
Yes. I get it to on Twitter and stuff.
Have you ever heard of this guy? I'm like,
do you know that you are the eight
thousands of person to send me
that they're Conley. The
catcher immediately where we
get to the brewers dug out.
That is not a good sign
for gene sucker off.
And there's a bodybuilder
named Maria cigarette. Yeah,
I get sent out every night.
It's a committed 80 miles an
hour, but still at all, nothing.
It almost sounded like it
hit part of the helmet.
Shit hit with a base
walking to first base.
That's a great sign. No.
Did he have a helmet on? He did. Right?
He did. Yes. Yeah. When we were, you know,
my previous girlfriend, yeah, we were
always telling him to wear his helmet.
So glad he did. Yeah, me too.
I've been hit in the head
with a playing doubles tennis.
My partner was serving and she
served the ball right into my head,
the back of my head. That was
really horrible. That happens.
It does. It's not good.
I hit my cousin Janette with
a baseball bat. What? Yeah,
why I was at tee ball and uh,
yeah, I uh, and I hit that. I hit
Brian rather guys and get the same bat.
So there was a tea set up. Maybe
you have played the ball. Yeah,
it was pretty bad at it. And we
were kids. We were probably seven,
eight and on the back swing I hit um,
Jeanette and the head. Well, why the
fuck was she standing so close to you?
I Dunno. So that was a whole ordeal.
She went inside or is a lot of tears.
And then it was like,
all right,
try it this time and this time I went
and I hit the ball off the tee and on the
follow up I got in the swing through
I clocked Brian and the jaw. Yeah.
As bad.
Yeah.
I mean there are a lot of tears and then
I ran home cause I was so fucking upset
and scared. It was terrible. I thought
I killed my two cousins. Yeah you did.
Yeah. Pretty bad. Help you stop playing
tee ball after that. That was it.
That was the last time ever picked up
a bat. Yeah, that sounds fucking more,
I hope our kid doesn't play tee ball.
It sounds like the most boring shit
to watch. It sounds pretty terrible.
So baseball is so slow, man. That's one
smart. I can't really watch for long.
That's pretty bad. Yeah.
I'm not into it at all.
What can we get them into that
involves indoors air conditioning,
you know like swimming.
Swimming is great, right?
Yeah.
Is he running?
That's outdoors shit or the indoor sports,
I don't know.
But I want to be able to be comfortable
in the, in the warmer months here.
Water Polo. Yeah. Water Polo. Okay.
That's good hockey you can do indoors.
That's dangerous. I don't like
hockey. Hockey is dangerous. Um, no,
no, no. Archery. Archery. Okay.
That's not a real sport. Oh,
you get them into martial arts? I
was always in dance. Good. Yeah.
That's air condition. Yeah.
Comfortable seating. That's
what you want, right? Yeah.
So what we'll show them, we'll show him
like we'll get a, uh, a pamphlet ready.
Yeah. Of only indoor sports that's
comfortable. Seating and air conditioning.
I'll be like
shoes and no traveling.
I don't want to have to get on airplanes
on the weekends to take him to games
and other states places.
This is like mother of the year stuff
and then when he goes a soccer
bag, it's impossible. Sorry. Yeah.
It's an outdoors work.
And also I don't want to have to bring
snacks for the entire team or be involved
in any way. Yeah. What kind of sports do
they have for that? Yeah. I think you're,
you're, you're really excluding a lot of
sports right now. Not a lot left. Yeah.
Soccer signers. Okay. Right.
He can't definitely outdoors and there's
definitely traveling. That's the boy.
Yeah. Yeah. Fuck how he can't
get hurt that bad. Right.
With soccer you can get hurt for sure.
You sprain your ankle or some shit.
No football. No. People get fucked
up playing soccer. Not every,
not every game, but I mean people get
kicked in the head and knees to the head.
You know how they break man,
but he's not going to play soccer because
he's going to have your built and your
stature and your body. You're not
built for soccer. I'm not sure.
You're built for couch.
What else?
What sports you lifting
things heavy things. Yeah. His
grandfather was a good, uh,
Olympic. That's what I'm saying.
He's got your bill. The segora built.
So what kinds of things or weight lifting.
There you go, that's, that's safe. Oh,
that's indoors. That's
indoors. Yeah. Not Snacks.
No. Fuck the bake anything.
Yeah. There you go. Weight
lifting. We found the sport.
There you go. I like
this. Hours of time. Yeah.
What else are you guys good at?
And that's pretty much it.
Just lifting heavy shit.
That's what he was best at my desk.
Both of you are good at Diane
broad shoulders. Really good. Yeah.
He was a top dog. Yeah. He called you from
the toilet the other day? Yeah, he did.
He showed me that he was using a handicap
stall. He always takes pride in that.
What is this here? Somebody
sent me this as this. This time?
Yeah. What was that? Your Shit.
Oh yeah.
You should take a whiff of it now.
Yeah. That's why he gets
robbed by me. Yes. I mean
Shit. I mean I wouldn't get it.
Yeah, I'm the same way. I don't care. Just
don't give a shit. It doesn't bother me.
Yeah.
Yeah. Piss on me. Beat me. Yeah.
Do you think that guy's a fan of your
mom's house down that footage? I Dunno.
It's unaired footage.
This is what our old one condo.
Thanks Troy. Yeah. You still have all
this artwork up here? Pretty Nice.
Damn. So it's like top dogs trying
it out before the try it out thing.
He started it off. We got some more tried
outbids you want to see him real quick?
Worse. Okay. Here's a big one right here.
[inaudible] wolf to fuck.
Fuck.
Like you're a high black guy.
He went fuck me at 2195
or you can move in. Yup.
Fuck me like a seventies.
Detective value is a
real actor. Big. He uh,
he's doing like the real dramatic
read. Yeah. I need to be fucked. A man.
Free food. Free Rent. Anything
else man? Here's the deal man.
Named from jail. Homeless. Fucking thug.
You want to move in?
You freaked the Morgan.
What she's doing for me at least to
keep, fuck me. Be me. I'm on your know.
See me. Want to try it out?
I can try it out. Why don't
fuck try it out. Try it out.
Let me try it out. It's
only fucking, let's fuck me.
I'm looking for hardcore guys. Meaning
do it. I want to fucking delivering.
I'm a hot white trash come
down really good. You know? Uh,
a lot of times actors are looking
for monologues to perform for class.
You could see it or yeah,
for stage.
This is definitely something that we've
shown to be very versatile as a piece.
And you take this into an acting
class, I guarantee you, you're,
you're acting coaches attention if
they go with the ice, this room,
some interpretation. Yeah.
You should just say, you know,
you got to give it credibility as I say.
Oh,
it's an indie film I saw was uh,
watching this thing on youtube and
there's this indie film, this guy, man,
it's really, he's kind of make
up a name, you know? Dude,
could you imagine if some kid brothers to
is acting class? Oh my God. Yeah. It's,
it's amazing.
It's so fucking gray.
I bet our guest today could do a real
read of it. Oh, we should have him do it.
Shots. EMST Kenneth [inaudible]
I sent as a shots academies,
German train 10% off the horse
person as he can pulling him.
No problem. Isn't it?
[inaudible] me to give me
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] she's [inaudible]
off shore managements. Amazon.
Let's fuck.
Oh Wow. I heard that.
Was it. Uh, what is it?
Black is Schwartz Schwartz is black. Her
to hit to be getting shots. You Kenneth.
Yeah. Really good. Good stuff. What?
This international submissions now.
Um,
so that is a act Akeem Akeem
is that how you say it?
A heme Heme,
I dunno.
Yeah,
it doesn't give anything back
in the building. As you do.
Try it out. Try It on and find out, man.
I'm just looking for some hot black.
Do it cause I'm a come down.
Whether you're in jail,
mental illness,
got a mental downs.
It's so funny if you want him.
This was somebody who,
what the fuck?
I need to fuck a lot.
Oh my God. Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
That's Calais.
Calais,
k a. L. L. E. I. I mean the auto tune
is something that's called autotune.
Yeah, that is amazing. Really
great man. Well my calm down,
but it's so funny he took that line
that we tried to figure it out. Goes,
what the fuck does that?
God Damn,
that was brilliant.
You guys still every single day send me.
Um, yeah, no, it's definitely
how a man out home. Yeah,
I'm home. I'm home here
right now. Told me. No,
I mean who knew that that one video
would spawn so much creative material.
So much sound a song and like guys
didn't love the fuck guys at worst.
Hey,
how are you?
He got caught trying to do it.
I love the work ones.
Sara.
I'm building my cardio for black guys.
You want to fuck you think you can
fucking me out of breath for you, right?
Try it out. Try it out for stroke.
Gang member tried out your friend.
I don't care. As long as you're
willing to fuck that like,
but try it out here on 2195 my home now,
but I'll be home later when we out.
That's my, yeah, that was great. He's
actually on a jog. That's amazing.
And then what is this?
This is another animation that came in.
No black guys fucking fuck. Good. Okay.
If you're a high black guy and you
want to fuck me at 2,390 moving,
I look,
he's got the blow.
Oh look, I'm nasty. Looks Terrible.
Fuck me now I need, I need
to be fucked. Free Food,
free rent and everything else, man.
Yet. Here's a doodle animation, jail,
homeless or dog. I'm going to
come move in. Frank can move.
It's two men and
we'll post that one to us from a ghost
toast while you're teeth are way too
white. And that animation.
Okay. The stuttering.
I love when they get the frantic
sputtering and the, yeah, yeah.
Movie to him.
Hot White trash come down off the truck.
Yeah, it's pretty wide. What's interesting
about Drew's last appearance? Um,
well there's a few things but also that
the mental illness and the drug use,
it's hard to tell which is which. Yeah.
Which was kind of a revelation. Like, oh,
is it math or is it just he's mentally
ill. Sure. So lots to think about.
Yeah.
Why don't we take a short break here
and prepare for our guests? Yeah, yeah,
sure. Sure. It about to arrive and farts.
Push the shit out. This shit out. Huge.
And
he really felt like I liked it. He got
a little defensive. He's like, well,
well hold on a second, let me,
um, let me address this. Like,
he wasn't just going to let that slide
because he does not believe that far.
It's pushed to shit or that shit.
Shit's, pushes the farts out.
He didn't completely,
wow.
We learned something every
time with doctor drew. Maybe.
Sure dupe many thanks to him. All right.
We'll be back shortly. You won't know.
As always that we paused
and we're back from the pause
you never knew about. Um,
and joining us as long overdue,
um, is really long overdue.
You may know him from standup specials,
a television shows and a,
you may have mispronounced his name
for years. Um, uh, I've seen it.
I've seen it live and in
person. I've heard you say
that before. Like people say,
I was with them, I was with them on the
street in Vancouver and they're like,
that's funny when someone says, I love
you, I love you Chris. Delea. Yeah, yeah,
they still Leah,
it's delete.
And it won't matter that I
said that though because it
will still happen all the
time. I say it. I make sure to say it. I
said apostrophes are until you know it,
message it. Really? No,
it's Sally. Sally, come on.
I don't know. No, it um, it's
Italian and they, they just say,
I mean people everyday Dalon Chris
long don't want to add an hell.
Yeah. It's like there's one
fucking, isn't that funny?
Like someone sees a symbol and they're
like, I want to fuck with that. Yeah,
I know. I then you go like, just, it's
phonetic dude. I know. Telia yeah,
I get, I guess Delea I guess
I could understand, but
people fuck it up way worse.
I mean, I've been on the phone with people
where they go like, oh, you missed her a
yours mine because they go,
I think what happens is you don't,
mine's not as intimidating,
but you know,
to some people at [inaudible]
and they'll start to go like,
I want to say this wrong man.
And I'm like, just sound it out.
It's exactly the way it seems completely
phonetic. Holy for now. Which of course
that's why I go by p the
letter p I always upset it. I,
I always knew I was dating or for real.
Like I was like,
I liked this girl when I could
spell it. Oh yeah. You're like,
I don't have to look it up or something.
I was like her diehard friend.
My real friends can spell my last name.
Now is your, is your mom Italian also?
My mom is Italian. Yeah, but she's
all, her maiden name is Dombrowski.
She's pulling the Broski.
She from the old country,
her parents, her parents, parents and
shit like that. Got that deep trauma.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know how much,
I don't know how much trauma is and we,
I don't know how much traumas
in her family, like early,
like way back when Paul locks. Are
they Jews to no Polish. Yeah. I met,
I hung out with the delay is
in Vancouver.
It was when he shot his last passion.
You were there the night before I,
something like that. I might,
yeah, the vogue, right? Yeah,
the vote and I was there the day
after you. Oh, you were? Yeah.
So you'd shot your
special like on a Friday.
Got Your mind was Saturday and
they didn't change the marquee,
which was really cool. I
did anyway, they gave her,
they were giving me shit about not doing
the alt show after my show. Yeah. Oh.
And I was like,
I'm done feeling,
it gave me shit about doing it after
shooting my special lights. I was like,
well, I'm not, I'm not going to do that.
You know? And the guy was like, we can't,
we're counting on you. I'm
like, for the alt show. Why?
They are like a cause. And then when,
when they were like a, you know,
like agents and managers were kind
of giving shit back. They're like,
you haven't even changed the Mark
Key. All right. All right. All right.
Are Bad on that. Yeah. I remember Josh
or manager would always just be like,
I remember he would just be
like, you can do it. You know,
they really want you there. They want you
to do it. I'll tell him, no, I could tell,
you know, I'm like, dude, I'm not doing
right. By the way, by the way, by the way,
though, me as me, by the
way, he did, uh, I did.
I was talking about him on my podcast
and they apparently like every like week,
like somebody like, dude, Chris
Lou talked to like in the business,
people like from ca are like, dude, have
you heard this? He's like, I'm heard it.
Alright. Wow. Because he
would always say, dude,
every time I would pitch a fucking
idea to him, he'd be like, well,
there's a show in there. He would
say and do it. And I'd be like, no,
it's a fucking show, dude. It's
their show. And they just want it.
And I guess tried to do the work,
uh, by the way, flush it out. Yeah.
Yeah. It was a lot of years we've
been hearing those fucking phrase.
I mean me and you were like his first,
yeah, two of the first I remember,
I remember meeting you in front of the
Melrose Improv. This has gotta be like,
oh seven w and I remember asking you, I
actually remember asking him like, Oh,
do you guys, or do you work with him? And
you're like, oh, he's like helping me out.
Oh Wow. Was that long ago, Jesus. And I
was like, what do you mean? You're like,
glad I even know what that meant.
You're like, like he's helped me out,
but I'm not like a clinic. So it was
probably, so what happened was I,
I had started doing
standup in 2005 and uh, I,
before that I was like,
like a writer.
Like I had made money optioning
scripts in shit. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
And um,
and I,
I started doing standup and my manager
at three arts named Stephanie Davis,
who was great. She would always
be like, you should do stand up.
And I would be like, yeah, I've always
wanted to do stand up like that in Maya.
Was your reaction in my, yeah, in my,
ever since I was a kid, I was like,
the goal is to be, do stand up. Oh
yeah, 100%. But it was always like,
I was always like, and I didn't know how
dumb that was. This was then, but like,
I was like, I'll get in, I'll get famous
first, which is like, everyone would hate,
hate me. Oh, I know. I
know. I know a few people you're talking
about comics would hate you. Yeah.
But yeah, no, that's like
the worst thing to do is,
is just you gotta you gotta you know,
grind and, and hit the trenches. Yeah.
But, but, um, but so, so I,
so Stephanie was like my literary
manager and she was like, um,
she was like try standup and I tried,
I did stand up and I did it for a few
months and because I was at this point,
because also my things that were getting
optioned, none of it was getting made,
so I was like, oh, this your writing
screenplays or yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I had a movie, uh, Kevin Spacey was
going to produce it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You must have been like, fuck, I was 22.
Oh my God. Yeah. And did you have, did
you, I was wondering this like, did you,
because your dad was in the, as
a director, yeah. Did you had,
had you read just dozens and dozens
of scripts, so you kind of, yeah,
I grew up in it. Yeah. So I
knew what it was all about.
What a shit script was and yeah,
yeah.
But also, but also like,
uh, like you know how like,
you know, I go up so much,
I do stand up so much,
like when I'm focused on
something, I'm like, I would,
I would literally sit and write for eight
hours a day. Yeah. I know. I can't
even fucking believe I did that.
Do you still do this ever? No, cause
it, cause it's all about stand up now.
You know what I mean? Like I,
I like if I'm pitching a show,
like I'll develop the idea and shit,
but I'm never like, I'm never like,
I'm always like, oh, I got
a show tonight. You know,
I don't want to do this new joke or, or,
or develop this or say this new thing.
So it's more like I'm about your energy
and just, yeah, exactly. My energy. Yeah.
Can I just say, I'm so impressed with
your, you're such a great performer.
You're always up great.
You're always great on stage.
When I see like a pop at the store and
I'll see you doing but an television too,
like you've done these sitcoms
and I'm always blown away,
hey you look great on camera
and B you can deliver.
Sometimes these jokes that like are not
technically hard jokes and they're funny
and you're like how fucking hard is that?
Because I took a Sitcom act in
class recently and it's really hard.
It's not easy to do sit calm acting.
Yeah. Well first of all thanks.
I feel like, uh, um, I feel like it,
the thing I, you know, I don't
know, but I think that it's, it's,
it's totally different.
Like it's just, it's not,
I think when you try to bring the same,
like I was talking about
this like cause comedian,
because comedians will be like ha,
cause they'll talk,
they'll ask me about like social media.
They'll be like,
how did you get a following and shit.
Like you can't like do the
same tone on different mediums.
You know what I mean?
Like, like if you're, yeah,
if you're a comedian
on stage doing standup,
like that's not the same thing as being
a character in a show on a sick. I'm,
even though there's an audience there,
and I always think about this like,
like when you're shooting is especially
for me because I'm real animated on
stage. Yeah. But like when I go in, I do
a show in the car at the comedy store,
um, I know there's people in the fucking
back. Yeah. You know what I mean?
So I can be as animated
as I as I need to be,
but like when I'm shooting a special,
I always have it in the back of my
mind that most people are going to be
watching this on their fucking TV.
So I don't really change much.
But like I know I,
in the back of my head I'm like,
there will be close ups. So like you
can't like put, like I've seen Comedians,
I've seen comedians who I fucking love.
I think some of the top comedians
and their specials, just, they,
they're just like excited that they're
doing the special and you can see it on
their fucking face, on the clothes. It's
two minute and it doesn't, it, yeah,
it's not their best performance. And so
even in standup it's a different thing.
Like if you're shooting something,
so if you're doing something as a,
an actor on a sitcom or, or even
if you're on a show, you know,
some drama or whatever the fuck it is,
it's all different.
And even on social media,
like you can't do the same shit you do
on stage on like, you know what I mean?
Like it's all different.
It's all different.
So I think that when you try to bring
the same energy but just doesn't work.
We were talking about acting in a
comedy versus drama and you're like,
you said that the dramas are the worst
because like you're there all day and
then you're like, hey, what
I cut. And like that's,
that's the fun of the show.
Yeah, it's, it's a, it's,
it's really like, I mean, when you're
doing a comedy like you do, you,
you're literally like, I don't know, man,
when I shot this movie
called Flocka dudes and uh,
it was with like all of these
great comedians that are, you know,
like a CML Hannibal. Uh, I mean, Brett
Gelman was in it. It was just, we were,
we were crying, laughing,
shooting the fucking movie and um,
and then you do like a drama,
like, you know, I mean,
I was on the good doctor last
year and it was just like,
you don't have that every
time you do a take on,
on a comedy, it's like you find out, oh,
this is funny too. I'll just this funny,
we'll do it again. This is funny
until you do it seven times, whatever.
It's so funny every time. But you know,
I'm talking to this doctor about like,
I'm the doctor, his neighbor,
and I'm like, oh cool. Yeah.
So how was work? It's like,
yeah, it's like you got, if you're
not, unless you're doing like a real,
like the doctor role is cool. You know
what I mean? Like, cause he's like,
it feeds them artistically and he's
playing this real role and he's got like,
but like when you're the
neighbor in a drama. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and, and I, I did
this, this movie every week to,
that's what I said. I actually
started doing it on stage. Like my,
I started talking about how like my worst
nightmare job is to be on like CSI and
for eight seasons be Rich's shit,
but be that fucking guy where you're like,
I'm way I had to type in. And you
know what I mean? Blow my brains out.
I flew with a,
what's the guy that played a,
Chris Noth played Mr. Bailey
and that sex in the city.
So we were talking all about this stuff
and he goes, he said, um, he's like,
he's like, you know, that role is like,
it was fine or whatever. And then he goes,
um, he was on law and yeah. Yeah.
How was, how did you like
that? He goes, well, he's like,
it gave me a lot of financial security,
but he's like,
every week it's the same print.
And you just go like, you're like,
we need to talk to that guy now.
You walk in and you're like, sit down. And
he's like, it's just repeat every week.
He's like, there's nothing there. He's
like, you know what I want to be on.
It was like Downton Abbey.
That's what he, he was like,
you know where there's like actual
real things happening. There's a,
there's the drama swells and
the stakes like, and he's like,
it's just like brilliant writing and he's
like this law and order bullshit man.
And then he got, he got
mad at the, uh, there's a,
there's a lot of flight attendant who
freaked out that he was on the plane cause
like, you know, women and she saw me,
she started to shake and he was
like, God dammit. I was like, oh.
He's like, he's like, not with American
Airlines. This is fucking Delta Bullshit.
They're, they're obviously not
professional. When she did that,
he should have just
said, sit down, sit down.
And then they're asking him for pictures
and he's like some professional, oh,
the actual, that's hilarious.
Tenants take a picture. I don't,
we were talking about this, me and
you. We don't cause Burt likes it.
What were we talking about? When people
come up we don't like it. Right? Yeah.
I'm just not writing me to speak
for you, but I'm like, first of all,
I'm super nice to everybody. Of course.
Like anybody says anything to me.
I'm always nice. Of course.
I'm saying that he relishes
the courts.
It,
we went to the national championship
game with a Ari and men.
People will be like, hey Burt. He'd
be like, do you want a picture?
Ask them if they want to take a pic.
And then they'd be like, all right.
You would be like, like,
yeah. So it was totally,
I don't like is that because it ends up
on the Internet and you look like Shit
for a minute? You know what
I mean? I never think of it.
That's I guess for a
woman to fucking Yvonne,
I'm always just like, I don't,
I don't, I don't know what is.
Um,
I'm putting expectations of the person,
I'm assuming them.
So I'm always like wondering where,
where you're expecting this to go? In
other words like, oh like you know,
sometimes I'll walk in, they're like, come
have a drink with us. I'll be like, yeah,
yeah, yeah. You're a
stranger. Yeah. I'm just,
I'm just going to say this is the one
of the first things you learn. No.
Well I'm Burt will like invite people
back to his hotel. I'm at the Hyatt.
That's cool.
Yeah.
One time he did it to the
audience of the show. He was like,
there was a performing and he's like,
oh so if you guys want to come
and they came in like drove.
Oh my. Especially cause they like we
can party with the party guy. Yeah,
well that's the whole brand.
Then the bartender was like out
of shit. Like what? We're not,
we don't even have the alcohol anymore
dude. I like, I have like in my head,
I have like, I like these rules
where it's like, first of all,
I think I was telling you, I don't
know what it is with me, but I think,
and this is not an exaggeration,
I eight or nine out of
10 times they come up,
they say something insulting.
Oh, right, right, right.
Like they don't even realize,
you don't realize it. And
I understand, I understand.
You know,
we lose track because we're around people
that we think are funny all the time,
but they're like, oh, oh, this
is the only, this is, I get
to see a comedian. I like,
I never have seen that. Right. Yeah. So I
get that they get the motor mouth thing,
but whatever you wanna call it. But
like, there'll be like, oh my God, like,
like, um, man, oh dude.
I always try to forget my friends
fucking hate you and always,
but I always stick up for you
like that and you're like,
and I'm, and I'm, and, and,
and so if that happens,
I'm not nice to you because you have
to understand that what you just did.
Yeah, no, I agree. Yeah. So I say,
did you just come up here to tell me a
bunch of people don't like me? Well, no,
but I do. Yeah, exactly. No, I'm trying
to say, aw, man, but just say your stuff.
Then at that point just say, Oh shit,
I'm sorry. I didn't know what to say,
but that never happens.
They're like, no, no, no.
I just go and I know what time your
mind, you know, you remind me of like,
I'll be like, what? You know, you
remind me of who? That guy, uh,
from the hangover. I'm like, Zach
Galifianakis. Yeah. I'm like, why?
Because we have beards. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You know who's
really funny? Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
That's what agents and managers like
to do too. But yeah, I don't even like,
but there's also like little ones that
are like, that kind of irked me. Like,
oh dude, my fucking brother's a huge
fan. Can I get a picture for him?
Always. Yeah. Like, you know what I
mean? It's like a friend loves you.
He's going to be good. Crazy that I took a
picture of it. I always say, Oh, not you,
Huh? Oh No, no, I'm not. I
like you too, but yeah, I like
to do cause della. But um,
yeah, agents will do like, hey, you sold
out the wheelchair and you're like, yeah.
They're like, that's
great. Who sold out six?
I had a woman come up to me once
after a set at the comedy store.
I still to this day don't know what
she was getting at, but she said,
hey. And uh, I was like, oh,
what's up? And she was like,
you really funny. And I was like,
oh, thanks a lot. I appreciate that.
And so, so far, right. The compliments
you really well. Yeah. Uh, she says, uh,
yeah, like super real, super funny. And
I was like, oh, thanks a lot. Like also,
that's the other thing.
How many times do people say it?
A few times and you're like, listen, I got
it the first time. You're like, hey dude,
you're so funny. Oh, thanks.
Like really? Oh, thanks. No,
no, no at all. Like, seriously,
I believed you the first time doing it.
I don't know where are you trying to
take this, right? Yeah, exactly. So, um,
so she doing that, she did it like
twice and then I said, oh, thanks a lot.
And then she said, I mean,
you know, and I said, uh,
I said, uh, I, I said, what,
what? You know? And she said,
uh,
I mean,
okay.
You know,
you're not like,
yeah,
amazingly funny. And I was
like, and I couldn't believe it.
And I said, what? And she
said, no, no, no, no, no,
you're funny. You're really
funny, but you're not like,
and she would do that. And I said, I
don't know what you're, what, what,
what is this supposed to go? And
then she, the way it ended was,
I mean you're not like Eddie Murphy.
Nobody's, that's what she said.
And I said, okay fine. I said,
you're just being rude. I get, why are
you pointing this out? Why their levels?
Just say the compliment and then the
weirdest one I ever had it because it
lasted too long and she kept, she kept
not saying things and I was like, Whoa,
come on, spit it out. But man,
one time I remember this guy came up to
me outside of the comedy store. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause Cause I, cause
I, he comes, he came,
he came up to me is a fucking kid.
He was in his twenties and he was like,
hey man, dude, my friends fucking
always talk shit about you.
They don't think you're funny but I
think you're the fucking funniest.
I go like this, fuck you right
in his fucking face. I go,
fuck you bro.
And he had his phone out to take a picture
and I walked in and he was like, oh,
what did I say? He knows. Why
do you think that bothered you?
It sounds like the compliment of
like the hate you, but I like it.
That seems to be the one that, because
here's what it is, here's what, yeah,
because,
because they think that they think that
there was, they're saying like, you
know, there's that whole thing, like,
it's Kinda like saying like,
oh, that bans great. Oh yeah.
I liked them before their album
came out. I liked them. They want,
they want to be in on the, on the thing
that other people aren't in on. You know,
that fucking bugs the shit out of
me. Dude. There's one thing to say,
I love your work. Thank you. You're
great. That's it. And you know what,
the other thing, the other
part of this is that, um,
that is lost on some people is that
they don't make that same concession to
their compliment to
other types of artists.
It's like if they saw the actor the thing,
they wouldn't be like,
you're a decent enough access. They would
just be like, I love you. And Yeah, yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No one goes up to the
fucking band and is like,
you're kind of a good band.
Uh, there's another bay. Yeah,
yeah. We're also out on the
fucking patio and shit. Like
I was starting to bred her and, and
he was like, dude, think about like,
if you love comedy and you're,
and you're like, and you,
and you live in Iowa and you're
on Netflix and you're like, oh,
these guys are amazing. You go to the
comedy store, you can just be like, Hey,
what's up? Yeah, it's true. It's insane.
Hit his lunch was saying, it's like, it's
like you, you go and you fucking see, uh,
you go, you go see Derek
Jeter at the fucking, you're,
you're at the Yankees game and then
you're like, oh, hey, what's up Derek?
And he's like, Hey, what's
up? Let me just think.
I'm trying to think from the perspective
of the audience member who's like, Hey,
my friends don't like you.
I think they're trying to be like,
just wanting to know I'm going
against all odds here. Like, yeah,
I'm kind of telling my
friends to go fuck themselves.
That's how much I'm going to bat for you.
You're that guy,
a positive way of thinking about it.
However,
you have to understand that that's
not how it's going to come across.
He's right though. I mean,
you know Delhi's right? You're
actually right to, yeah,
you're right. But I'm trying to think
like why would someone would be like that?
Cause they're like, I argue with my
friends, I defend you. You're my guy.
Also,
there's this one,
there's this thing that happens in
people's heads that they're not even fully
aware of when they meet a comedian in
that is that especially one that they just
saw. They're like, you just
made all these people laugh. Um,
I have a moment with you.
Right.
And they want to say something either
really funny to you or insightful or
memorable. And so they, they kind
of go like this, it, and they,
it's a verbal diarrhea and
let you know I had one.
And Alcohol,
alcohol is a factor.
Comes up to me after this coffee
goes, uh, she goes, Holy Shit,
that was fucking hilarious. And
I go, oh, thank you. She goes,
but I'll laugh at anything
that makes me mad.
Great. And then her friends are
like, she's a fucking idiot. Yeah.
She said that thing don't I
got, no, no, no. I get it. It's
fine. It's fine. Yeah. I've,
I've had a bunch of those,
man.
I've had a bunch of those that you're
just there just like you kind of want to
go. Do you know, I also, my, my pet
peeve one is I find it super annoying.
It's like you walk, let's say, uh, from
a club into like the shit bar room.
Most people are gone.
There's people you always,
or maybe it's like the hotel across the
street and like somebody will be like,
oh. They're like, yeah,
they go pretty funny.
Oh, bad. Rude. That, I don't
know. I acknowledge that.
I'll be like, yeah, that drives me nuts
because it's like, Yo, they're in my head.
They're like, I got shit to you. You know
what I mean? Like I'm good at my job.
Like, oh, you're cool now.
I just bought a ticket to see me and you
left your ass off and now you're going
to be cool. It'd be cool. To me,
to me is the equivalent of literally
looking at someone and being like,
you're not bad looking.
And you're like, what?
Oh yeah. Pretty good. As so
dismissive. I get that from men. Men,
men say
what it is guys or girls and guys all
feel like you don't want to feel like
they're bowing to you. Right. You
were like a reserve. I will say,
I bet Chris gets it more
because he's your eye.
To me it seems like a lot of like
young girls like you, cause you're,
you know what I'm saying? Like your
demo is, yeah, maybe like cuter, hotter.
Not like Tom was a salmon.
Mostly dudes.
I get the guys that look like me
and yeah, true. They have guys
that come to my show look like
they have health problems.
I always joke about, I'm like,
I've never see, uh, there's,
there's no crystal his audience. It's
significantly better looking than yours.
Like let's just, absolutely in
court would be proven. Correct.
So I'm imagining that you have these like
cute girls in the club too, by the way.
Sorry. In the clubs. So there'll
be like delete was here. Whoa.
I didn't know we had people that
looked like that in the city.
That's what I'm saying. They're
all good looking. So the,
the guys must fucking hate you.
It's gotta be hate daggers.
I do get, I do get like
sometimes like the guys are like,
like 12 like do dudes come out to see
me like together and they're like,
we listen to you in the fucking thing and
are like, Oh God, they think I'm like,
Damn. I'm like so not that guy. You know
what I mean? Like, but um, but yeah,
biggest stabilized. Okay. Do
you get into Twitter battles?
Are you talking about, you're talking to
the fucking grand slammer, right? Yeah,
cause I don't pay attention too much,
but I imagine you'd be one of the people
that would engage. It's just my wife,
he doesn't lash it slot. People
say to me like, you know,
you should really let that go.
You know, like people are like,
you're better than that.
And I'm like,
there is no fucking way I'm
better than that. I'm that good.
However good you think that is. That's
exactly the level, dude. I just,
my one of my faith and people are like,
you shouldn't let it get to you.
It's not even that it gets to me. And
I'm not saying it never does. Of course,
sometimes it does, but it's, it's
so fun. That's the whole thing.
I think it comes across that you're having
fun. Oh, okay. Good. Good, good. Me.
It's good to know. That's good to
know. What's your, what do you, what,
what turns this is what I love about it,
dude.
This is what I fucking love
about it because first of all,
we live in the age of the Internet,
which is fucking bullshit. Okay.
Because a guy who's not even close to me,
who I don't know,
should not be able to say anything to me.
That's it. The rule, he's not in
the room with me. I don't know him.
He shouldn't be able to talk to me.
Okay.
We live in a world where everybody
likes that can talk to me. Okay.
And, and that's in my head
fucked up. All right. So,
so the fact that that person
can just like, dude, you okay?
And it's hard to do this without
sounding like a pompous or whatever.
But like if I, if, if,
if when I was a kid,
if I could reach out to like people
that I like, oh my goodness, I,
that would have blown my mind.
Like I remember I met Jim Carey once
and I didn't wash my hands for like four
days, but now people are just
like, let me just tweet him. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah. You Suck
it fucking in this movie. But so,
so now,
so now the fact that
somebody can do that okay.
Is and the fact that I can
tweet, uh, you know, whoever, uh,
Tom Hardy, it's a, it's a, it's
a luxury. It's a privilege. Okay.
Yeah.
So if you're going to be able to do that,
they, ah, I'm just discuss,
nor is going to see, you know,
he's going to see this. No, fuck that.
I'm retweeting it now you get to
see how my life is, dude. Yeah.
I'm retweeting this and I'm
giving you a fucking, I'm,
I'm giving you a shot or whatever
the fuck you want to call it.
And now everybody gets to talk
shit to you. This is all dude.
What the fuck is not cool? This is my
life, motherfucker. This is how it is.
This is,
this is that you've entered,
this is exactly what you wanted and this
is what life is. This is the Internet.
You get to talk to me.
Oh everyone gets to talk to you now.
I always thought I was crazy too, when
somebody will talk shit and then they go,
ah, they talk shit. And if you put
them on blast then they're like,
it's really not cool the way you shared
it with everybody. And you're like, yeah,
wait what? You shared it with
everyone as soon as you tweeted it,
it's the internet. The fact, the fact
they are freaks you out the most.
What gets under your skin on Twitter?
Um, well here's the other thing. I'll,
I'll go look at my name.
I don't look at just cause I
want to see the negative shit.
So I'll just type in my name.
I did it the other day.
I look at my name because I was like,
I can't wait to retweet some of these
guys and like talk shit cause they don't
fit because they don't think they have
like 36 followers and they're like,
I'm just going to say fuck it.
And then I love to,
I love to think of them going to sleep
and then waking up and being like,
what the fuck? I like having just replies
and then, cause I know, I know they get,
I know they're a hoe.
They're heart beats a little bit.
How, how laughter.
I've seen you do it tomorrow.
People,
obviously the biggest one
ever was this Logan pool one,
which I know you've probably
discussed as an ad nauseum,
but just to some people that
are not really asking about, uh,
that's the youtube guy.
Young guy has like fucking
crazy and he has like millions,
millions of subscribers on youtube.
Millions and millions of people
follow him on social media.
He's a very young demographic.
Um,
and he got in a lot of shit
obviously when he went to Japan,
he was filming blogs and he made one where
he went into like the suicide forest,
filmed the dead body and then,
you know,
made his video and then people around
the world, we're just like, dude,
you need to reevaluate your whole Evan.
He know he went off for a while anyways,
so he's,
he tweets out that he has a video that
like everyone needs to see or something.
And Chris just goes like, no, they don't.
And this guy is like,
uh,
this kind of goes right here.
Oh yeah.
I'm laughing because I know why your
comedy career took a dive, which,
so that's what this guy says
back now when you see that,
what you called it on the top,
we come back.
That's the name of the is we can
come back. Um, so when you see
it though, yeah, you see it, uh,
you're, you're, you're adrenaline's
going right? Like you gotta be excited.
When I saw that, I was like,
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Like,
yeah, I was like, so like,
oh, I almost was like, oh no.
Like this guy. Like what is he doing?
So you had a very calm assessment.
It was very calm. Yeah, it was very
calm, but it was excited in my, in my,
in between this and you w w
what is soon to be the greatest?
The Grand Slam. The Grand Slam of all
time. How long does it take it? It was,
it was a few. It was not like
a few minutes to read it. Yeah.
And then when you drafted it,
you knew you had a fucking I,
that was just the one I knew how I knew.
I was like, that's just what I was like,
this is what, this is what
the joke is. Like, there's
no like, that's look at this.
So this is what Chris responds with.
At least when my career dies,
you can film it and put it up on Youtube.
Retweeted 150,000 times
and liked 665,000 times.
All right. So I got it. I didn't think
it would do that. Anyone assumed? No,
it was a good one. Yeah. I literally was
like, ah, this is the right thing to say.
It's funny. You know, I would think it was
funny if I, I imagine someone else say,
I'd be like, Oh yeah. Would be like,
oh wow. It is like when you know,
like when you've done roast roast,
most of like the,
like the real experience roast writers
will tell you when you're gonna when you,
what the approach to writing a roast
joke is actually do the thing that you
think of when you think of that person.
In other words, if you're roasting,
um, uh, a giant fat guy, you
go in there like if you, like,
if everyone thinks of,
well that guy's enormous,
that's the wheelhouse because then it
becomes a relatable joke. Right. You know,
so if, if the person is, if the
person, everybody knows the thing.
So that's the people, that's how he
was introduced to. Exactly. Yeah.
So it's like, it's like a
perfect, that's great gross joke.
Cause it's like it's a put down,
but it's not like a two aggro. Yeah.
I didn't want to be person. I mean, I
guess there's a little bit personal,
but not really. But like I wasn't,
yeah. Oh Man. Great. But yeah,
and then I, and then I went to bed and
then I woke up and it was like, you know,
200,000 likes and shit.
And then like he must be getting texts
from people and everything. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Dude. It was like doing the
tonight show in the 80s people,
I would be walking down the street
and people are like, hey man,
got you back from Logan.
It's like so funny, Dude.
It was like a, but he tries to come
back and then I started to be like,
dude, I just like just like, don't,
he's losing delayed. So I was like, yeah.
I was like, I don't want to keep going.
I didn't want to really keep going,
but I will because I'm me and I'm like,
I love it. You know what
I mean? You are. Thanks.
And how does it feel to have your name
finally attached to something fun?
Oh my goodness. Okay. But
people, it was like, it was,
it was, it was not even really
the credit goes to how much he,
people didn't like him. Right.
That was what people were retweeted.
That's true.
Not necessarily I made the joke,
but it's,
it's because it's attached to somebody
who's done something fully unlikable and
you're, yeah, but I mean, he, he was like,
he like people didn't,
people hated him before that Japan Shit.
And now there was a reason
where it was like, oh great,
because you mean he would go in,
annoy the shit out of people
and be disrespectful and
shit. He was like the, the,
the, the Tom Green, but the tongue green
was funny. You know what I mean? Like,
but like what was like,
okay, but be funny,
any like followup to this whole thing
and anything like as far as like somebody
reached out to you from that knows
him or anything like that or no, no,
not really. No. I mean,
he, he, uh, you know,
I don't know the guy for all I know, he's
in, in the, on his phone just like, oh,
this is funny. I was just fine, I'm
having a good time, maybe years. And, um,
if I met the guy and he was nice fucking,
oh cares, like I'm, yeah, no, I'm not.
And like, you know what I mean?
Like if you do something fucked up,
which that was pretty fucked up what
he did. Yeah. Um, you know, may,
maybe he genuinely doesn't, you know,
he feels terrible and he's, who knows?
Maybe he's a fucking reformed
good guy. I don't know. But,
uh, but like, I, you know,
I fuck up you fuck up. It's of course,
but it's like on Twitter, it's like, it,
did you hear from anybody who you've
never heard from in like supportive?
In other words, he was like, oh
my God, like famous. Yeah. Uh,
I don't know. I saw some people that
retweeted it that I was like, Oh wow,
that's funny. Oh, right. Like
bikes, I can't remember. I
can't remember who, but like,
uh, um, you know what? I
posted it on Instagram. Yeah.
I posted it on Instagram, the
screenshot and like, people like,
like Steve [inaudible], Steve Urkel
was like, wow, man. Oh, like, yeah,
like that kind of shit. That's
great. Um, yeah, so stuff like that,
people are like, I don't want no part of
you, man. I don't want any business with.
Yeah. Like Dylan Mcdermott was
like, Nice. That's so funny.
Um, hey, so give us your, we were
watching this. Tell your, uh,
your assessment of, uh, what's
going on with this girl.
I need some dick badly.
I'm fucking tired of wasting
this good ass fucking pussy.
Oh yeah. I'm fucking tired of it.
I'm fucking tired of my pussy.
Just fucking white spin.
So do you feel like,
um,
would you ever have
sympathy sex with someone?
Like would you throw someone a bone
that you're not that attracted to?
Well, she's attractive. I'm saying I'm,
I'm relating something
that's not necessarily really
do this. I'm just saying,
would you, would you ever throw,
I don't know. I'd never have. Um,
you never like, uh, you know,
not, she's not, but she's,
cause that's not where my
brain was going with this.
And then I was thinking of like this real
homely girl one time on a cruise that
I was like, yeah, I knew it was
because of personal experience.
Some girl you bone on a cruise,
some pink, and then you did it.
I ignored her. I can't,
you never told me this.
I've known for 13 years,
14 years when we got to bring it up.
We'll talk about are I want to
know. So was she real fat? Was she,
no, she was just like, Eh, I want to, uh,
she was just kind of like
lagging behind and I was like,
I kind of want to talk to her cause she
looks broken and talks about what else,
what happened was the next day, uh,
when homely was like, kind of like, hey,
I was like, and then, uh, and then I,
I got a direct line to the one
on one to 10. How old are you?
35. 36. I was a 21. Oh Wow. Yeah.
Very that my dad was on the cruise too.
No, he, well, he kind of
knew. He was like, he was, um,
you could tell it was like
he was keeping it, you know,
he wasn't being like gross.
And he was like,
it's funny like to watch you like you
kinda like lay back because he would see
me before he would go, he
would turn in real early, you
know, but he'd be like, Oh,
I see what you do. You kind of like lay
back and you kind of like assess like a,
like a, like a Hyena.
Yeah. Yeah. He was like,
and then he's like,
and then you kinda make your move after
you've assessed the room. And I'm like,
well I'm alone.
I'm alone with my dad would call vulture.
I wasn't one of these guys who was like,
cause some of the guys,
especially at that age, you know,
really like talk, talk, talk, talk,
talk to everybody. And I
was like, wait. So, okay.
So I was relating to you that I,
I've never, I've never done that,
but I don't think, I don't think
I would. I Dunno. I Dunno. No.
So this animal though, she, um,
I don't know. We're trying to,
I was first we were trying to,
we were like playing,
thinking about her as being real. Then I
was like, maybe she's doing a bit like,
cause she knows she would get,
but then
I want to get fucked Neil.
Okay.
I should be able to get fucked when I want
to get fucked. I work so fucking hard.
I deserve to be getting my
face fucked right knee. Okay.
Big Cock in my throat. Yeah.
Yeah. Suffocate me. Sucking dot.
You got to fuck tablet and fuck
who I want to fuck up there too,
but wouldn't that my pole whole
thing with this is like how,
how are you having a problem getting,
because she's doing it for views.
I mean it's a legitimate request
for Dick's in her throat. No,
I mean there's plenty
of guys that would do that. I, I don't, I,
it's like if you're going to be a slut,
BF slept for real. You know what I mean?
Don't, don't joke around about this
shit because this shit is real life.
Real slots get offended.
This is the game dude.
Yeah. Yeah. If you, you know,
you can't be all, oh, you know,
go go to target and say this shit,
fuck my face. They're going to see Dan.
We'll see. Cause that's what I'm saying,
it's not hard for a woman to get that.
I get you want you want, you don't
just want any guy to fuck your face.
Sounds like she does. Yeah.
But if she, but she would go,
I mean she could go outside and just
doing like a homeless guy or guys out of
jail or even guys that she isn't feeling,
you know,
it's like she wants yeah that is annoying
as shit cause it's sure for views and
all that and that,
that is just,
I mean talking about the Internet
did to me that's what's wrong.
That's another thing wrong with it.
It's like just a little taste
shit or whatever the fuck you,
you've seen it a little tay. Yeah. Which
is like nine years old. She's like,
I'm nine years old. I got my money.
Then you bitches. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was really gross.
Will your parents,
they're probably posting it.
Yeah, they are. I'm sure.
But like, what are you doing?
What are you doing? And then, and
then the, and then the, um, the,
how about now?
Cash me outside girl who saw
her on Dr Phil and was like,
Oh, I want to see her rap. She
has an album now. 10 million.
I looked at, I looked
yesterday, 13.5. Wow.
Who the fuck I get like, you know, you
know, in 10 years are going to be nobody.
But like that's generous. Generous. Yeah.
But I mean like, okay, well
yeah, maybe you're right. But
I mean, I hope so, but like,
it's like, dude, you're the glorifying
the idiocy of America, I guess.
But it's like, it's so fucking weird,
man. That's somebody would look at that,
catch me outside girl and be like,
what else you got?
You're a real talent.
That's so weird to me. No,
it's too saying you wouldn't eff
that girl. We just saw that girl.
No Way. That will be a fucking
insane. Well, first of all,
she's crazy. Oh yeah. Uh,
right there. She's crazy.
No, because we see these
videos so much. Then I'm like,
I can't tell is it mental illness?
Is anybody that would put that on
there is a crazy person. Yeah. Yeah.
Well I haven't dated since the 90s.
Friendster was around when Thomas, right,
right. Yeah. No, that, that, yeah. I
don't know this shit anymore. Yeah.
I was trying to find this one
was getting it on cruises.
Was it a carnival cruise? Might. It's
a real bottom of the barrel today.
And cruises are horrible.
You know, I went on to,
I had one good time. I was 21 and I
went with a girl and it was so fun.
And then I went on a fucking
cruise on a bachelor party.
I don't want to jump off the worst.
You ever done the Gig on the cruise ship?
No,
no, no, no, no. I came real close.
Yeah. Um, I got a call and I, you know,
I didn't have that much money
and, and the agent was like, no,
you'll have to do like this
welcome aboard thing. Oh No.
And then you'll have to
do like to clean sets. Oh.
But then you get to do one dirty set
yet to and yeah, but the good news is,
and it was like $1,000 more than I was
used to making it right. And I was like,
I think I remember this is like,
and I feel like something came up like
an international gig where I was like,
oh, I actually can turn
this off. It was relief.
It was when I turned it down
I was like, oh my God. Oh Wow.
Cause I wasn't prepared to turn it down,
really, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They were, I was this close to
getting an offer to do Olivia cruises,
the lesbian one. Oh really? This
is when we were living rampart.
Division. Yeah. There was talk of it and I
was like, I don't know. I'm not gay. Am I
exactly what I'm talking about?
She us out to God.
Why is she screaming?
Love to see the person just
shooting it. Just so like, man,
where's her house?
I don't know.
Nope.
Okay. But by the way, those people,
unless her parents are rich,
like she's not making that much money.
She can't know. There's no fucking way.
There's not, it doesn't. I
like what, what it's like,
it's like these,
the girls on Instagram that are like,
have like 10 million followers
that are like, where they're like,
buy this tea or fucking coffee,
scrub body shit.
It's like their, first of all, uh,
their followers are all men.
So then they can't sell shit to ladies.
They're not making that much money.
That what does, what does, what
brand is paying her? Like what, what,
what brand is paying her? What, what, what
is his Windex paying her? No, it's brand.
It's like, and there's no, uh, there's
also that's like the, you know,
the big thing is like, there's
obviously no skill set there.
Well, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, and, and I get, and I get that
if you're 12, who cares? Just like,
I want to watch that shit, but like this
is the, the, the following of a spectacle.
You're just watching this, right?
It, that, that is just my God,
man. You guys have kids.
It's like, imagine ever going
to happen to our kid. No.
Yeah, no. I, I, I obviously, but I mean,
just imagine if you had that
kid that was like, okay,
I don't want to go shit girl,
she's going to be at the House of Blues.
That's the thing is that they all have
these tours. He's like, this girl.
Nah, Bro, come on, we're
all going man. Nah,
be just like the next day I'd be like,
I bought you eight books last night.
Um, yeah, so she said, you know what I'm
saying a lot. This is apparently, uh,
somebody who drops
everything like that a lot.
Oh yeah. You know, we had our odd
man rush there in the first period,
which is not good for us,
but I mean everyone had their nerves
going and everything like that. And then,
which we're glad to just keep them
to want and everything like that.
And then we went back and after
a period in the locker room,
just talked about what we need
to fix and everything like that.
Stick to the game plan,
get back on it and everything like that.
So that's one up deep trance
and everything like that.
Oh, anything like that?
Oh No, come on. I'm coming
in here to the tournament.
I got nice shot long text from him this
morning saying, don't let the atmosphere,
uh, you know, get your nerve shaken up,
play your game, which is what I can
do out here. And everything like that.
Definitely helped for a moment.
Anything like that, the big matchup.
Um, it should be a great game.
I can't wait to play him.
I know they're doing good.
Only one last on the season
I believe and everything.
I'm kidding.
He doesn't know. I know. Here we did
it for him. Here's a bunch of your,
everything's like that man
and everything like that and everything
like that and everything like that.
Everything like that, everything like
that. Anything like that, you know,
like and everything like
that and everything like that
and everything like that.
Jesus Christ, I guess, you know what,
seeing that makes me feel a lot
better for people coming up.
Give him a backhanded compliment.
It's like,
you don't know what you're saying though.
And especially, you know, with, uh, with,
with people, with the athletes period.
At any level. So like sometimes we,
we expect a, uh, just a,
a better a hero and also just somebody
to be as articulate as a broadcaster.
It's just the guy that fucking skates
and bangs his head against shit.
And then he's like, and everything
like that. And we're like,
how come you talk skin?
It's like as I,
I hit stuff and everything like that,
it doesn't know what he's saying. Whoa.
Is that a new thing
and everything like that?
I think so. Oh man,
that's hilarious. Well,
2016, man, that's
something that's so funny.
His friends have talked that sock.
Do you know what sucks if you're not
famous and then you become famous for
something that at least with like
you guys, it's like, oh yeah, but we,
I got a body of work, you know, might
know me from, but like, oh my God,
that guy just being being the fucking,
or being the guy who like fell down
and got shit on his eyes are like,
that's your, you are being, I mean this
is a more dramatic example, but this,
this lawyer in New York who's a,
you know,
he was like screaming at people for
speaking Spanish and like that. Now it's,
that's you forever. Like you're the racist
lawyer. No matter what he ever does,
he'll never get away from that white
lady who called the police on those.
Oh yeah.
And she deserves it. That's even
smart. People are like, well,
you deserve that.
You know what I mean?
Like that's barbecuing with a
man that when and then when,
and then when everybody went and had
the barbecue the next day, it was the,
it was so that shit is
just did that thing.
But I think reminded me of kids where
you remember when like when you're a kid
you can tattle tale and then if
somebody or somebody goes like,
this isn't something,
that's how you get emotional because you
kind of know you did something wrong.
Yeah.
There's a camera on her.
Someone's filming her when the police
arrive and she's like, yeah, I know.
She starts breaking down.
It's like,
I think it was breaking down because she
knows. Yeah, she knows it. She's fought,
she's fine.
But she starts to twist it
as I'm so scared. This whole,
the meme of that lady or the funniest man,
like Obama and Michelle Kissing
and she's in the background. Just
the moons are the best. Uh, fuck.
The Internet is so great though.
Never lose that shit. Yeah.
The royal wedding. We love
those memes that came out.
Like people were cutting
in coming to America. Oh
yeah. Oh, right, right,
right. There was that one. Oh,
the cause it had the black preacher
and they laid, um, uh, what's his name?
Uh, Arsenio Hall as the
preacher's audio and it looks,
it kind of matched really well.
Very, I won't have Randy Watson.
Fucking amazing.
You know what sucks is like,
I try so hard to come up with jokes
and be so funny and it's just,
I just feel like it.
You'll never be,
I'll never be as funny as some bullshit
like that yet. That's a skill too.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, yeah. No, I know.
I know. I know. Yeah. Fuck that.
That's so funny. It's pretty
great. Um, so wait, where's this?
Oh, the check this. This is
a lady who definitely has,
I don't know what the fuck is going
on with her, but she goes into
Taco Bell.
And when's the last time you ate
Taco Bell? I know. I know the answer.
I know the answer. Okay. I was 19.
That's a long time.
It was a long fucking time ago.
And it was in union square
in New York City. And what,
what made it the last time
I ate Taco Bell, I walked,
I ate it all at the Taco Bell.
I walked out and I thought,
I thought I wasn't that, that
wasn't, that wasn't that good.
And it doesn't feel that good.
And I thought,
I'm never going to eat taco
bell ever again. And I thought,
you know how everyone always says
they're not going to do something,
but then they always end up doing it
again. This time I'm not going to do that.
And I haven't eaten it in
fucking almost years. It's been
19 years because that resolution
to stop eating Taco bell too,
had it in Wisconsin.
After the shows in 2011 I drank three
glasses of red wine and Taco bell was the
only thing open. I hate when
that shit. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I had a Mexican pizza and a bean and
cheese burrito. Great. They're great.
And I want,
I tried to sleep at two 30 in the morning
and I wanted to vomit all night long
and I, I did the same thing. Never
again. Never again. Never again. No.
Neil Hamburger,
I don't know him personally,
but you know about us.
Have you seen the Taco bell thing?
No.
He's one of my favorite social
media you're talking about.
So what Neil does semi irregularly yeah.
Is He will go on Twitter and
use the search function to,
and he'll just type in like Taco Bell.
Yeah.
And retweet what people are writing
about Taco bell and it's all shit.
Like I threw up a of Taco bell.
Taco bell got me feeling,
I feel like I've been poisoned. I
think Taco Bell poisoned me. Uh,
fuck you talking about just
puke Taco Bell. I do like,
it's amazing. It's funny.
It's absolutely fantastic. Um,
yeah, he uh, he fucking a man.
Is that him by the way? Yeah, that's him.
Jesus. I didn't know what he looked like.
What he does that,
um,
is he the guy that goes hamburger
knows that Hamburger Jones. Okay. Yeah.
That's shit kills me.
Yeah.
I remember seeing that on def jam like
the first time I saw that I was on the
floor. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I was like, I also had
that thing where I'm like,
there's no way he's going to keep this
up. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I came to find out like
that's 100% is that, that's so funny.
Cause he doesn't curse. So every time,
really first he says hamburger. Yeah.
I mean, yeah. So it's like
he'll never be that funny.
I won't never be asked to Ham
Burger. They're like, yeah,
I mean it's shit like that that makes
want to quit. I'm like, all right,
well I give up. Then we were
talking about, um, earthquake
doing a gig somewhere,
and my agent, your agent to
was like a, he's like, man,
it was like so devastating the
level he was killing it. Oh.
He was like, you know, it was like,
like the building was going to
call like fall down and he goes,
you'll never kill that
hard. And I go, oh, I know.
And then I could tell he was like, I
mean, I didn't mean like you won't kill.
I was like, dude, I know exactly what you,
yeah. And by the way, I will never, right,
right, right, right. Yeah. I've been in
rooms where, oh dude, I went to, you know,
Donald Rawlings, right?
Yeah. Like just, I mean,
planes could be crashing into the
Improv and you wouldn't notice.
That's how hard he's killing. Yeah. Right.
So I remember they wanted me to do and I,
I,
I, I don't, it's not my favorite
gay, but I liked doing it.
Cause I know sometimes the students want
want like guys that they like and shit.
And I, and I know sometimes they ask
for me, but like the, um, the, uh,
the rose bowl shows at the
Improv, ever do those? Uh,
okay. So I guess people don't
know at home, but like every,
every year, whoever's in the Rose Bowl,
a football team, the football teams,
they'll have two shows, one for each
team. And they're always at like 5:00 PM.
Yeah. And, you know, they'll reach
out sometimes, I guess if a coach was,
the coach will be like, these are the
comedians we want or something. And, um,
so they asked me and, you know, if I'm
in town, I'll do it because, you know,
it's cool. The kids are there, students,
you know what I mean? Like there,
so I go in and I, um, and I'm
like, who's on the lineup?
And I don't even really ask
this all the time, but, uh,
I was like, who goes online?
And they're like, Theo,
Danelle, a few other guys. And
I was like, great. I was like,
uh, she was like, um, this is the
lineup. Tg sends it and it's going to be,
I just remember last year was going
to be Theo, me and then Danelle.
And I was like, I was like, uh, oh cool.
Uh, I don't want to follow down out.
Right. Yeah. Cause that guy just
murders. Yeah. Yeah. Um, but I won't, if,
if the lineup were to
come out and say, Hey, uh,
it's going to be Danelle and then you,
I wouldn't have said,
can I go before Danelle? Because
I, I, part of me is like,
I want to see if I could do it right.
Do you know what I mean? Sure. So, so,
so I get there and I'm,
I arrive and as I arrive,
I'm walking into the Improv and I
hear utter destruction on stage.
Okay. So I'm like, oh,
this is a great crowd because whoever's
on his murdering here from the
peninsula. Yeah. And, um, and I go up to,
and by the way, Theo is fucking
hilarious. I followed Theo all the time.
I know how to do it. I don't follow
done all, all the time. Okay.
So I've never done it. So, so I'm a,
I'm on after Theo and I go in and as
the destruction is, I'm, I'm like, oh,
it's probably Theo on stage right now
because I'm showing up almost at my spot
time as this is happening.
The destruction out of the
showroom walks Theo. He's like, oh,
what's up? And I'm like, Hey, what's
up? I was like, uh, oh shit man,
they're running behind, Huh? And he's
like, no, not don Nelson. And I was like,
Oh shit. So he got here early and
he's, he was like, Nah. I was like, oh,
so you're going on next? He's like,
no. I went on and I was like, oh, uh,
uh, so, uh, there's only one
more comic and it's me. Huh?
And he was like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, you can crush them, man. And
I opened the door to the Improv.
Uh,
I mean,
every single all men 260
plus pounds because of the,
there were football team,
they're all standing up.
They're standing up going like,
oh, they're all screaming,
jumping up and down shirts
like this and Nell is singing.
He's just like, it's
like, it's like, uh, uh,
it's like the joke of a black
church, whatever it would
be. He's like, Nah, Nah, Nah,
Nah, Nah, Nana, Nana, Nana.
That's what he's doing.
And they're fucking,
people are on shoulders are fucking
losing their minds. And I say, uh,
I go, I walk and read a company
anxiety, right? Dude, Rita, Rita though,
you know the Rita? Yeah, she comes up
and she was like, she literally is like,
you're going to do great.
And I'm like,
you're only saying that because you
know I'm going to hit my fucking Dick.
I'm going to you.
Nobody can follow this.
I'm going to eat my fucking Dick. I
was like, just end the show ended.
But, but part of me is
like, ah, fuck it. I'm like,
I haven't bombed in a while. Fuck it.
I'll just go bomb. Who gives a shit?
But then like, you don't want these key,
you want to like make these kids happy,
you know? So it's like, ah, how fucking go
up. And Theo was like, oh, you know what,
open up with that, uh, thing about
how, because it was happening.
I used to have a bit about
how one black people laugh,
they relu locate and know to get up
and they move around. Totally do that.
And that's what they were
literally doing. So I was like, oh,
I'll fucking open with that.
Thanks. The, oh by the way,
I haven't done the joke in seven years.
It was my first special. So I was like,
I'll just do that. I guess it's kind
of annoying that I got to do that,
but fucking, and I can't, I, you know,
I don't feel confident enough. But, um,
I went up in that, that bit ended up
doing that bit, did really well. And then,
but then it like, it like
was like, I was like,
thank God I'm only doing 15 minutes.
Cause it was like,
there's no way I could sustain it. So it
was like, yeah, it was like he murdered,
he murdered and it was just like
petering out very slowly. And I was like,
I had to do crowd work. I was
doing crowd work. But man,
I mean like aren't good at that though.
Well thanks. I mean I had to do that,
but do it, I mean, I don't think I've,
there's been maybe two or three times
I've seen something crushed out heart.
I cannot believe what Donald Rolling
does. Donnell Rawlings. Yeah, I've seen,
um,
now there's no feeling to,
especially when you're like, it's,
it's so when it's like, this is going
perfectly for that person. Like, yeah,
like every line and like the audience
has absolutely losing their minds and I
definitely want to go like,
no, no, no, no, call it. Yeah.
Yeah. Well I'm filming this,
the degenerates of comedy. Oh
yeah, that's right. That's awesome.
And they added the six person and you
know how it fucking is Brad motherfucking
Williams. And the first
thing I tied to Josh, I go,
I am not following Brown.
Yeah.
He crushes like that to
where there's nothing. No,
you can't follow Brown ones.
There's no falling that you see.
There are some guys like that that are
just, I mean Joey Diaz, Joey to me,
that guy too. They're tapping on
the same night. Oh yeah, go for it.
He's going to go last.
He's got,
I mean like, yeah. Uh Fuck. I
met him one time. I was walking.
I mean it's funny dude, I've walked into
the commies store wants enjoyed Diaz.
He's just like, I know that
you're a fucking pussy and
everyone's just like, Nah.
And I'm like, and I walk in and I
literally walk in. I go, oh for fuck sake.
Like cause I'm next. You know,
it's so funny. I love that though.
Cause it's so like I failing is so
funny man. You know what I mean?
Especially when
you're going to be the guy to
fucking eat Dale, it's coming.
You didn't know it's coming after
you've done this a while. Like when,
when you're like looking
back, I feel like you, you,
you think of more adjustments,
oddly enough, earlier on for me,
I totally agree with you
doing like now if I'm like,
if I'm after someone just lighten
the place on fire, I'd be like,
I'm still just going to go up there and
it's either gonna work or it's not going
to work.
And I'm like a slow starter.
So if I follow someone killing
lots of times people will be like,
I don't know what you're doing. Like it
takes maybe for a few minutes. But yeah,
always been like that though,
is that you've always known exactly
who you are and what you're doing.
You don't adjust for anybody.
I don't, I don't address it.
Don't make any adjustments.
And like people who like,
like my dad who doesn't know
shit about company and be like,
he's been to shows where he's like,
uh, how come you don't like, uh,
maybe try to make it for them.
And I'm like,
because I went to that strength and
that's something I wish I would've learned
earlier. Cause I, I'm the
monkey that's like, wow. Well,
I'm going to do it this way.
How about this way? You know, I don't
do it as much now, but oh my God,
the hardest I ever bombed.
I followed a black guy.
We're basically doing a black
guy compliment. But yeah,
it was a guy in Canada and it was all,
it was a Canadian show,
all white audience obviously.
And um,
his name is tricks and uh,
and in the, in like 10,
15 minutes into my set, somebody
goes, bring back the black guy.
Like they actually yelled at and then it
went downhill real. It wouldn't really,
really bomb. Like boo booed me off. Really
asked me to leave. Yeah, yeah, it was,
it was 2013. It was a week. I
always remember this detail.
It was a week to the day that
I shot my first special after.
So I just thought was so interesting
that like at the time you're a career
highlight during a one hour special,
one week to the day later booed
off stage later. It was after.
Wow.
That's a neat part about standing.
I know you can feel great about yourself
and then you can feel like a total
piece of shit then oh that's interesting.
Great.
Like showcase of what standard it
can be to people. Shoot your special
with the special like with the
material that is your special.
Oh that actually makes me feel better
because it's like that's cause it's cause
your specialist fucking
hoe cause your hilarious.
But to be that funny and then
to just have it not work,
it makes me feel better. Like when it
happens to me, you know what I mean?
Like there's nothing like bombing.
No one is never better than the room.
You know what I mean? It's
like, Oh the other, by the way,
the other person who I've never seen
anybody killed this heart in this room.
I've seen people kill. I've had good sets
there at the comedy Magic Club in her,
most of the rod man. Have you ever seen
him? Oh, I know that guy. Who's that?
Oh wait, who is that? This guy. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh yeah.
He was on last comic. Yes.
Yes. That's how I know he did.
He did a couple of sets at Merck.
Really?
Like the kind of shit we're talking
about. We're like, he's closing this out,
right? They're like, well now he is.
Oh right, right, right, right, right.
Shows can call this show
while over. Yeah. Yeah.
They did it to me when I was starting to,
uh,
headline the Improv's is they always
put a black guy is my feature act,
I guess for diversity. Thanks. And I'll
look guys do not fucking put the blinkers.
So fucking fun. Yeah. Yeah.
They're fucking whores.
So funny. Um, all right. So check out this
live. We didn't watch this before. This
lady.
What are lie?
Yes.
Okay, so it was lady goes in there,
there's a camera rolling. So she's,
she's dead wrong. She's wrong. There's
no youngest at this point. You Go,
oh my bad. Yeah, let me get a Taco
or I'm going to go find Burger King.
Those are the two choices. All
right. This is where she takes,
that's helpful.
Anything that's held
by the way.
So for people listening, she's
wearing like a workout, you know,
like a almost like a sports bra.
Her, her belly is exposed. Right.
It's got headphones around her neck,
Adidas track pants and you're like,
all right. I don't know. It's coming
from the just do it. Her post workout,
Taco Bell Burger King eating. But,
but anyways, it's been the lady,
the person working there is, but it has
handled it correctly. Oh definitely.
We don't have French fries.
This isn't burger came so far.
She's being held.
Just tell me,
tell me what you guys,
okay. Also still she's like,
yeah, but she's getting irritated.
Yeah. Person. But she's also like, I like,
I know this, this lady started to say,
what do you sell? That's
like French fries. I yeah,
that is what you said is
actually saying and the lady,
the lady behind the counter is like,
the menu is above my head as it is
in all of these types of rights.
And by the way, you don't have to read
it. There's pictures, right? Yeah.
There's no extra thing that we don't have
that's up there so you can read there.
Anything that's like a French fry
that you think you can get that. Okay.
Here to do. The turn is gonna. Okay.
Tacos and Burritos. So happy.
Cause you had four eyes.
Pretty good. Pretty good
come back or that guy? Yeah.
The girl who was asking for fries said
this is racism at its finest. Wow.
And then other patrons of this Taco bell
where like they have tacos and Burrito,
that's what they have right
here. So you know. Wow.
And now this girl is,
first of all,
she's getting emotional about,
is she on something?
It's, it's either or. It's really a game
of like, is it mental illness or drugs,
which is a bad game show.
Yeah.
Every day you go to Burger
King to laugh at you.
Good.
This guy's good.
Whoa. So again, the other,
the patron was like,
what did you go to burger king and order
to lap. Yeah. He's pretty good. Yeah.
Which I love. It's a very
specific fish. He didn't say,
he said to lap pretty good. Very light
fish too. Yeah, it is very, yeah.
I don't have French fries,
French
fries to nothing to me.
There's something else I'm going to
go mental illness, maybe not drugs.
Maybe cause he doesn't seem manic,
she doesn't want it to illness.
It makes it less funny and uh,
I just want somebody to know,
oh, you're not familiar
with the show. Sorry.
I usually doesn't deter us. Um, yeah,
I mean she's definitely going through
something. Maybe. Maybe it's a,
she's just went through a bad
breakup and she's just, you know,
that's funny then that's fine.
It's funny she broke up with her or a guy
who love French fries are always like,
um,
and then here's the best is that she
asked somebody else if there were French
fries. That's what she just gave away.
And that other person was like, yeah,
you're at Taco Bell. Okay. Now. All right.
So if you were in the Taco Bell at this
point, uh Huh. What would she be doing?
You would be doing nothing, right?
Just watching ear to ear smile.
You heard it.
Your smile.
I would be praying that the guy
that everybody yell and be like,
I hope he's got something else.
That'd be
so excited. But you would stay.
Stay away. Stay out of it.
I think I would have to say something
like, let's say like right now,
because this turns like,
um,
unstable emotional behavior turns
me off big time where I got like,
I don't want to be, but I'm a true,
I'm amused at the people interacting.
If she said something really fucked up
or insulting, let's say to the workers,
yes. Then I would jump in. Right,
right, right, right. Yeah. No.
When I see crazy unraveling, I stepped
back and I enjoy, just make time.
If it's crazy, if I know it's
crazy, then I won't engage.
But if I'm like you, but she's
probably crazy. I won't say anything.
Fuck you bitch. Get me fries. I'd
be like, Hey. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no fries anywhere.
Even on the block, like, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. Well she really handled it really
well. Really have the cashier. Yeah,
she really did. Wow. Wow.
Wait, is that viral now?
People are going to be going in acid for
French fries though. Keep going at that,
but yeah.
Hey guys,
go ahead and send us your
videos asking for French fries
now.
Del Taco or Taco Bell.
I think probably Taco bell's better del
Taco. I, I've probably had in my late,
in my early twenties. Yeah. But, um,
I was, have you heard of the Burger?
I don't del Taco.
It was kinda good,
but I haven't eaten fast food
and I mean I've eaten in and out.
But besides that clean, are you a
pretty, I mean, dude, I honestly,
here's what it is.
I eat pretty clean until
11:00 PM and then I just,
I, I, I'm hungry real comics. I was like,
I gotta get something to eat because
what time are you going to bed?
Usually relates to 2:00
AM that makes sense.
So you sleep and usually I, if, yeah. If
I have nothing to do. Yeah. Like even,
even this, I was like, even this when you
were like 11 o'clock Monday, I was like,
oh good. This way I have a reason to
get up to get up. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Yeah.
But you have, you know, you
have a young, yeah, yeah.
That's all we've been making
fun of. Scat singing. Oh yeah.
You know the scat man right out of the
things you need to do to learn to scalp.
Right, right. Listen, I'm
learning a skill, especially
literally even a skill, right?
I mean,
do you need to learn seriously?
And then my son does this. He's
two and a half. He's a pro. Yeah.
Wow. That guy is so serious about
that. Super serious. And now there's,
you know what hand boning
is? Uh, I know that word.
What is this guy's a ham boner.
Um,
and he also incorporates,
I think he incorporates
scatting into it too.
Hambone it's just going to anger
me. I know it. I'm like, oh,
it's the combination.
You're good at it too.
It's completely useless skills combined.
Uh, see the, the Internet people will
just fight. I was like, Oh, this is,
you can do anything and just
have a fan base. Absolutely. No,
you don't know what this is. I want
you to be, don't be, don't be alone.
I've seen this guy hit her or do this.
I bet couple of minutes,
his ball smell better than his beard guy.
I've seen this.
I've, you know why I've seen this
guy. Somebody made a meme about it.
I forget what it was, but
it was really funny. Oh,
you can go fuck himself because I don't
think this is a fucking talent either.
Oh fuck off with the share sells more
tickets than I do this size, this place,
man.
All three of us.
Oh, for God's sake. Oh fuck
off. Oh, just hit them.
You're doing it. Whoa. Hold on.
At what point in his life did was he
has these old is this as career was this
was like he was the guy. Cause it
makes sense in 1930 right, right.
Like you can't hear the instruments.
Yeah. It's good to have from the air. Yes.
Yeah.
But it's not,
it makes me so annoyed when they laugh.
Oh, me too. It's not a talent.
Oh No,
it's your drunk grandpa at Christmas.
It's not a fucking skill with this
asshole smile. Look how impressed he is.
That guy, that guy. It's
his fault. What will like,
I want to know what that guy
sees all the time. That, that,
that this makes him smile. What does
he see? Just war all of the time.
Just people getting hit
by cars his whole day.
People. Yeah, and then
he's like, oh, not war.
That's literally what he's
thinking when he sees that guy.
Oh my God. Fuck off. Yeah,
here we go. What's so funny?
You know what? Nothing. Nothing, Bro.
I hope we get shot at the end of this.
We think,
I literally think an hour I could do
in an hour. I keep going over this.
I can figure out 80% of it.
Yeah.
Oh fuck off.
Do you think you sell CDs afterwards?
Here's all right. Here's the grand
finale. Ready to receive those?
Graph it out himself.
Okay.
All right guys, I have a question for
you. Okay. Who is more talentless? Yeah.
The person on Instagram who's just like
the model and then they do meet and
greets and they make like
Cameron Dallas for instance,
he's millions of followers and they did
these tours where they just meet greet,
right. Or this fucking asshole, like
who is more talent, who has less talent
I think.
I think
we're just to remind you, God, I don't
like what's more personally,
I want bonus in the group. The
ham bone. I'm inclined to like,
Cameron's a good question. The
Internet model like that. Okay.
It's beauty is in an eight thing.
You're, you're blessed with it.
It's useless though. Just like that
one's you, it's a, it's a good question.
It's a tough question. Who's more talent
list? Yeah. Like who makes you angrier?
Let, let's go with the field. Well that's
different. This time makes me angry. Yeah.
He makes me angry.
But I feel like the,
the cute kid is less talent cause
it's Keith all he said, but he said,
and he's handsome. He's a model. He
modeled, okay, let's put it this way.
Mumbling to scale.
Modeling is a skill.
I think it's what people buy tickets
to meet that kid to me. Him. Yeah.
This people, people buy tickets to watch
them do that. Do that fucking fuck.
Yeah. He, um, I think that, fuck this guy.
There's this guy, I mean I'm just
trying to find the argument here,
but this guy at least
figured out something to do.
That's it, you know,
um, the other guy and,
and trick people into coming to see who's
the real asshole, I guess. Yeah. I mean,
I mean,
ah,
no,
no.
Three of us went like how we would
be crying. I mean to eat an apple.
Can you get through who's more talented?
Him or the staying alive?
Staying alive. Show Christina.
What's that? You'll see. Oh
yeah, that's a good idea.
Well, in the meantime, you
know, let's, let's go through
the logic here. See that is,
here's the other thing, like,
um, Cameron Dallas, right?
His name that is cute. And that
his day, United Day in those days,
a Latin those days,
even that I pay money
to see this guy do this
is here.
I think he lives outside.
Uh, but I'm going by the, uh,
the forehead lines and not all,
not all of you two feet. Can I tell you,
I feel like he's more talented than that.
Fucking I like this more.
Yeah. I like this was way more,
put it this way if you were watching a
movie. Yeah. And over the soundtrack,
this came on be way more
interesting. Yeah. Yeah. You'd
be like, oh, that's cool.
What is this? Or if you walk into a real
guy, he'd be like, what does this fuck?
You walked into a room and there's a
small stage and this guy was doing this.
You'd be like, I know that song
and go, but if sold, I was like,
you'd be like, fuck this.
Got Men. Absolutely.
Well, but, but why?
He doesn't know the words down low.
Jajuan Bennett.
So I by no,
no [inaudible] United.
Oh God. But this guy,
this guy has got charisma.
This guy's got an angle.
The other guy feel like he's a hoodwink.
I feel like he's, he's been brutal
with me. That's, that's a good feel.
Jipped when I see this, the old fucking
wire, the intention is, and you know,
if he's doing it well, see, cause you
know the song, you know the rhythm.
So if say United,
you know what to say United. And so when
you hear someone singing it, you're like,
I like seeing you.
But
you don't even know if that guy's
hand boning. Well, like when he,
I bet I,
I guarantee you there's other
ham bonuses that are like,
yeah,
this guy fucking suck.
And then they're, they're more
mad than we are. They're like,
this is the fucking guy. Yeah. He
never closed with the Po. You never
know. There's another guy was like,
you know, that is my thing. Yeah. Yeah.
That's true. How long have I
been doing that? A long time.
Right? You're right. Yeah.
And then obviously you just go, you
didn't even pop on that one. Yeah.
But the amount of it, this is intricate
too. There's a lot of moving parts.
He's got to sing the song. He's
got to do the lung infection. Yeah.
Part.
What's emphysema?
Dr Juke came in and said it was, he's
got, he say was upper respiratory issues.
I don't think you need to
be a doctor to know that.
Wait a minute,
how is this guy
that long and know what this guys,
but that's why it's so amazing.
He's a medical marvel.
He's working against what
he looks like the last guy.
Ah,
okay.
Stuff happens.
There is rhythm and he's like,
he's one of those guys that if you saw,
if you were standing there and you
had loose cash in your pocket, yeah,
he's doing this, you might be like, yeah,
hell yeah, but not fucking old there.
There's also a,
just on a behind his face,
you know,
you're like, you feel for him. Yeah. The
other guy is like smug and you're like,
this fucking guy. Yeah. This
guy you want, you are like, oh,
I can see behind his face. He's like,
maybe you know, I mean, maybe he's crazy,
but like you're like, I feel for
him, like he wants to entertain you.
I feel like it was a warmth
or something. Yes. Warmth.
That's what it is. Yeah. Yeah.
That guy. What? This guy wants to put on
a good show. Yeah. The lung infection guy.
Yeah, but the other guy, the
other, uh, but yeah, the, the, the,
Oh, for fuck's sake, dude. That's funny.
Do you buy the, you saw that lady,
the Tim Horton's on the right. Take a
shit in Tim Horton. Oh yeah, I saw you.
I saw it from your thing. You
repost it. Oh really? Yeah. Crazy.
You know what? In my head I was like,
I was talking to my opener
and he was like, uh, what the,
what the fuck you think happened?
And I, I like, I was like, oh,
she's saying I need to use the
bathroom. They're saying, no, you can't.
You need to buy something. And then
just like the only thing we discovered,
first of all, you're right, cause
we looked at, is it? Yeah. Okay.
But the thing that also came out,
is it the reason that they said no to
her specifically is because she was a
known problematic. So like it's like
she came in okay. And then like,
hey guys know that it's then it, yeah,
she's, well it's a crime no matter what.
But if,
if I didn't know that,
if it was just me doing it and say I
need you just let them know, I'd be like,
I would,
I,
my thought would be like I should shit
on their floor and then give him the
business and we'll see what's up.
Yeah. Yeah. So I could understand her,
but if she was a known person than
not. Yeah, that's crazy. She, I mean
everybody has been,
we've been talking about this.
Everyone's been sending in
their, um, their try it out. Um,
videos. Do you know what I'm
talking about? No. Try it.
So this thing with your show. Yeah. Yeah.
So this guy has a video that we play and
try it out. Yeah. Oh yes. No, I know,
I know about it. Yeah.
What is it? It's this guy
black. God's love. The
fuck the fuck. Look,
if you're a hot black guy and you want
to fuck me at 2195 if you want on the
move, then you come move in because
you got to fuck. You got a funny,
I need to be fucked a lot, man. Rent free
food, free rent and everything else, man.
He has a deal, man. Woe, jail,
homeless or a thug.
Want to come move in.
Frankenmuth cheer, man. Free Rent. You
could at least in the case. Fuck me. Piss.
Somebody beat me at home.
Ya know,
he seen me when I come up with today
and try it out, try it out, man.
See my bills and tried out and I
fucking pissed. Let me try it out.
She has applied only as fuck,
man.
I'm looking at the hardcore gosh and mean
if you want to do it and I want him to
deliver it. I'm a hot fuck my
trash come down. So fuck oof.
So that guy, yeah, he has a,
he has, wait, where do you find that?
Well, now people find them for us.
It comes to us. So yeah,
it's, it's been, oh my God,
it's been so much since
since that came in.
So what was the thing you're trying to,
people were trying to do it,
we want people to use it as a monologue
and kind of be creative with it. Like,
you know, an acting class for like
bringing a monologue. That's kind of,
so people have been just, you
know, doing their versions of it.
Fuck, you're a high black guy. He went,
fuck me sending these in
love to fuck
right.
I'm building my cardio for black.
You want to fucking fight.
Good. You think you can fuck me out
of breath. This guy did it. And Jeremy
[inaudible] in German.
Um, so and then, uh,
the week before we had a bunch
of women did it. You know,
black guys who like to fuck and fuck.
Good for hot black guy.
Black guys that love.
Nice props. Wardrobe.
Why guys love to fucking fuck good?
If you're a hot black guy,
you want to fuck really
animated by a lot of energy
back. I slipped a second. Jesus.
She looks like she's
getting fucked. So, uh,
yet will you do one for
us? Sure. Just, you know,
camera. Yeah, I'll sit down. I'll send it,
I'll send it over if you want to shoot a
good though, I'm gonna use a real camera
and I would love to see you do it. I mean,
people will become real dramatic. Like
a real interpretation. Yeah, yeah, sure.
I'll get to get it a lot. I get a live
studio audience. I'll do a sitcom actor.
Okay. Black guys who love to five black
guys like the fuck. Fuck good. Yeah.
Try it out.
Didn't try it out is really,
I feel like honestly the
guy was just winging it.
But I think that getting to the try
it out part earlier. Yeah. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Cause I don't know how long that is,
but if you got it too with
like a 35 second banger. Yeah.
That would just be true.
Then you can move in, but you got a fuck
or moving. You're moving. You get fuck.
What accident is that?
We've been trying.
That's right. Cause we're kind of place
it is moving. It's east coast for sure.
Yeah, try it out. Try it out. Try
it out. Yeah. From a building.
Do you want to know the
big mystery? What? So we,
we played this audio for a lot of people.
There's one line where he goes, um,
he goes, piss on me,
beat me, beat me on me.
I know that last part,
whole minnow.
So a lot of people thought he was
saying how a man out like piss on me,
beat me homie on out. Whoa man.
Out Ho Ho Ho me on out. Like,
he's like,
Oh hold me on out or Homey homey on it.
Oh homie on outcome or a
piss. Somebody beat me
at home, Ya know? And,
and then there was just like all types
of submissions to what he's saying.
And then we,
we,
we decided that he must be saying he's
like rambling through it and he's saying
home here now, cause he gave out his
address before. Oh piss on me. Beat me.
I'm like, you can do it
right now. No home here now.
Like, hey, a forensics on. Yeah, we
have resumes on it. I tried different,
it's like that Yanni a Laurel did
you find out? Do you know what,
what it actually was being
said, but I know what it is.
It's actually Laurel. Yeah,
well it,
well they say that if you're old enough
you can't hear the higher frequency and
the higher frequency he recorded. Oh,
recorded saying Laurel. Oh really?
So he on an interview, he goes, we
said Laurel, but you're right in that
it's also a device. You Yanni, right?
I was 100%. I was Laurel, it was
a, and he said he's saying Laurel,
but the pitch either that you naturally
here or the pitch that your device is
playing.
So if it's a higher pitch,
cause I put somebody played on
their iPhone is like, wait, what?
That sounds like Yanni.
Yeah,
but how funny would it be if
he was talking and somebody
was just like, oh yeah,
Coz he's Coz again, he and they're like,
what are you a fucking lunatic? Like,
like I said, Laura, that's
insane. It's insane. Um,
Maria now in the building.
Yeah, he, it, he refers to,
are you in the building?
If you're in the building 2195 and
now I'm here right now I'm pumped.
Homeless or a thug.
He says men from jail.
I mean, he's born, here's my address,
men from jail and bring a friend,
which is
how is like sexual desire and preference.
You have no control over it.
That's the craziest thing is if you want
to get fucked by a bunch of jail people
in jail, and that's what
turns you on. Oh, well yeah.
That's how the cards fell. Yeah. You're
like, just cut it out of my brain then.
Cause that's what I feel. I
know. Yeah. Well, doctor drew
says it's a lot of trauma.
It's got a lot of trauma and he's
kind of, you know, dealing with, yeah,
but you're right. That's the hard,
the hard wiring with the trauma.
That's a good sound bar. I told my
fucking intern and make it sound bird.
It's the fucking worst thing in the world.
It's a worst thing in the world.
Or really, you just click
it in a habit. I click it,
I'm waiting 20 seconds and I'm talking
about something else and it's like,
okay, I fucked by a black guy. Oh, by that
time I'd be like, I'm like, it's over.
Yeah. Um, all right. Uh, oh.
So I don't want to forget. Um,
just let me pull this up. Chris, did we
do, how long have we been doing this?
We've been, we're, we're over the two hour
mark. Luba box. You need to come back.
You're such a great, I can't wait
for you guys to ask me. I'm never,
the guy was like, let me be
Parcast, you know, but I, I don't,
I want to do so few podcasts, but
obviously I want it to do yours. Well, no,
we're so happy you can't cut.
Chris is on a big tour right now.
He's doing a lot of venues.
Go to Chris delea.com.
Click on the tour and you
can see coming up in a,
let's see the count Basie theater in
red bank, Wilmington, Delaware, uh,
Redding, Pennsylvania. Tulsa. Looks
like it's going to be close to, or,
okay. See Midwest City Dallas. They're
all at crystal IA that come. Um,
how's the tour been going? Fun. It's fun.
Yeah, it's so far. It's good. I mean,
I kind of just started, but it's been, uh,
it's been good to do theaters again
cause I stopped, I did it like years ago.
I did a theater tour and then I was like,
I want to do club.
We were talking about this
and I want to do clubs,
but then I was doing like 40 shows
and I'd like a DCM Prof. Yeah.
You're doing Carnegie Hall. Oh
Wow. Pretty cool. Yeah. Very cool.
Have you done yet? No.
No, no. I'm not there
yet. She is. All right. So theater,
that's it. And then of course, uh,
congratulations is the the podcast.
Yeah. I have a lot of fun doing that.
I didn't think I W I didn't know if you're
one of the few people that could pull
off the solo podcast too. Yeah. Uh, yeah.
I was like, I'm, I, when I started
I was like, oh, I don't want to do,
I don't want to have to rely on getting
guests. Yeah, of course. That's,
you know what I'm saying? We had
no guests for two years. Oh really?
That's the reason. Oh, that's
cool. We just, we were like,
let's just do it our way.
And then, so why did you start getting
guests? Just because it's just the studio,
but you can do it by yourself. Right? You
still do. Sometimes you'll do it by, yeah.
Yeah. That's cool. Um, yeah. Um,
I don't know. And then I was like,
I'm just going to do it. And I
was like, uh, and I was like,
do people do it solo? And I was
like, I knew bird did it solo. Yeah.
And then I think like Theo started doing
it around the same time I did it and we
were like, Oh yeah, you do it by yourself
too. And, but uh, but then I was like,
cause I was like,
I don't think I can do an hour talking.
But then after like two episodes, I
was like, oh, I get it. What do you do?
Do you go in with like a Kinda like,
just like, uh, I mean, uh, sometimes not,
but sometimes, um, I'll have
like three or four things. Like,
you know, like this happened, I'm going to
talk about it. Yeah. Like if I, if I like,
yeah, exactly. Like the Taco bell thing
or if I saw it or like, you know, or like,
uh, the met gala we'll talk
about that happened basically
like a riff thing. Yeah.
I see what you do. You go in there and
I get bits out of it too, which is cool.
That's cool. Yeah, we've gotten bits
out of it. Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
And your Instagram's very funny,
right? I liked the, I liked the,
those highlights too from the pod.
Oh, oh, cool. Funny. Oh thanks. Yeah.
So go see Chris live or of course
he's at the comedy store all the time.
Listened to congratulations.
Come see all of us at the comedy store.
All their bro. This is
uh, a song. Let's see.
This is therapy breakthrough by Pete
Sake to take us out and I think it has a
bunch of, uh, trying on out there. Try
it out and Dr. Grouping her phone. Oh,
I love it. Great. All right. Thanks
guys. We'll see you next week.
This
is
twisted
schizophrenia please. Lack of
empathy.
I think it's a red one.
Frantic and complete. Lack of
empathy
till death.
Do you think curious around Calico
is both. I swear to God. Oh, well
it makes me,
I,
I hate who I'm becoming socially.
I've never considered that
my out of my mind. Right. Crazy. You know,
when you did get like real rape,
like I fucking killed the guy.
What'd you do as a kid? Twisting rabbit.
What'd you do as a kid? Twisting?
What'd you do as a kid? Twisting next.
Picture it fucking rank right now.
Don't go there when you're
talking to a sick person.
I'll really piss us off
and then he'll let it,
and I know that you suspect
that my husband is a psycho.
He's a functioning like,
get to know their habits.
Really verbal. Tick.
Something's really wrong with me. Verbal,
tick. Something's really wrong with me.
Verbal ticks, something's
really wrong with me. Verbal,
I'm an audio
is like
you're a
psycho.
Look on your face.
[inaudible].